[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
votre grande émission parlementaire du
mercredi le nouveau gouvernement castex
vient de terminer la séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement à
l'assemblée
dans une heure il sera au sénat vous
allez pouvoir suivre tout cela en
intégralité et en direct sur public
sénat avec nos journalistes alexandre
poussard et steve jourdain et alex tente
c'est donc aujourd'hui est bien le
baptême du feu pour le gouvernement
hewitt a mais c'est d'abord la première
au sénat de jean castex le nouveau
premier ministre et qui vient de la
droite et qui se dit très attaché aux
territoires et aux collectivités locales
il devrait donc recevoir un accueil
plutôt bienveillant de la part de la
haute assemblée ensuite il y à une star
eric dupond-moretti nouveau ministre de
la justice qui devra répondre à une
question du président de la commission
des lois philippe bas sur les réformes
qu'il entend mener dans le monde de la
justice
également sur ses relations plutôt
conflictuels avec le monde des juges
et enfin on verra comment l'hémicycle du
sénat à majorité de droite accueille ce
nouveau gouvernement
également à majorité de droite avec des
anciens fidèles sarkozystes comme gérald
darmanin bruno le maire et roselyne
bachelot qui occupent des postes
importants
merci beaucoup alexandre pour toutes ces
explications à tout à l'heure
avant cela pendant une demi heure on va
consacrer notre débat sur ce plateau à
ce nouveau gouvernement ses chantiers
prioritaires ses premiers pas et les
premières annonces de jean castex
ce nouveau gouvernement est pour
l'instant accueilli fraîchement par la
droite et par la gauche au sénat
le groupe de la république en marche
dans sa majorité soutient bien sûr même
si certains dont la gauche peine à se
reconnaître dans ce gouvernement qui
penche plutôt à droite flora sauvage un
tiers de nouveaux entrants et une nette
coloration à droite
aux yeux de la majorité aient l'air au
sénat le gouvernement de jean castex est
plutôt décevant car il ressemble
beaucoup au précédent selon philippe
dallier n'y a pas de surprise il n'y a
pas d'effets blast comme certains
annonceurs du côté du château à l'elysée
c'est plutôt un non événement surtout le
sentiment que c'est un gouvernement
d'individualités aux ordres exclusif e
du président est celui qui veut se
représenter aux élections qui donc va
tenir la main tenir la rampe tenir le
projet une critique qui émanent aussi
des rangs de la gauche où l'on
appréhende le retour des gis les jaunes
force de prendre un virage à droite ont
fini par aboutir sur un rond point
je pense que le nouveau chemin
aujourd'hui est assez décevant
j'ai le sentiment qu'il ya une forme de
bunkérisation du pouvoir qui reste droit
dans ses bottes en espérant passer en
force
et si c'est un passage en force je
crains le pire pour notre notre pays
nous aurons un mouvement des gilets
jaunes puissance 10 au sein même du
groupe en marche qui est minoritaire au
sénat certains sénateurs commencent à
douter de leur positionnement
je me pose des questions ce quand j'ai
rejoint le groupe en marche
la gran doctrine et à droite et la
gauche
bon force est de constater qu'il y a
plus un tournant vers la droite que la
gauche mais pour le président du groupe
en marche françois patriat
il faut laisser le nouveau gouvernement
faire ses preuves il ya ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont capables avant même
d'avoir gouvernement au travail
avant même d'avoir déjà vu les décisions
qui sont prises critiquent déjà le seul
à écouter ce qui ne laisse aucune chance
à personne de pouvoir faire quelque
chose je les laisse à leur turpitude
pour certains dubitatifs les sénateurs
pourront se faire un premier avis dans
quelques minutes lors des premières
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
et pour en débattre sur ce plateau jeu
le plaisir d'accueillir laurence
rossignol bonjour bonjour sénatrice ps
de l'oise vice présidente de la
délégation aux droits des femmes je
précise que vous êtes ancien ministre
des familles sous françois hollande
également avec nous lors darcos bonjour
un jour sénatrice l'est républicain de
l'essonne vice présidente de la
délégation aux droits des femmes et
membre de la commission de la culture
également avec nous enfin jean marc
gabouty vous êtes sénateur rds de la
haute-vienne et vice-président du sénat
et à distance en visio et bien nous
avons également avec nous jean philippe
moinet bonjour vous êtes un e orateur de
la revue civique et initiateur de
l'observatoire de la démocratie
alors tout d'abord d'un premier tour de
table qu'elles signalent pour vous
envoie ce gouvernement laurence
rossignol
un gouvernement de droite c'est ce que
nous indiquer un certain nombre de vos
collègues notamment groupe écoute et
j'en suis encore à me demander pourquoi
le présente dans les publics à changer
de gouvernement
j'ai toujours pas compris quelle était
la raison
l'objectif de remplacer le premier
ministre qui n'avait pas démérité dans
la ligne politique qu'ils avaient
élaboré ensemble et loire philippe
edouard philippe bien enfin pour le
remplacer par un nouveau premier
ministre et on a un nouveau gouvernement
qui quand même recycle un bon nombre des
ministres précédents du présent
gouvernement les chocs d'attribution
plus de vedettes connues des français
pour à la fois leurs compétences dans
les fonctions qu'ils ont exercé
auparavant mais surtout pas pour leur
image cathodique pour bachelot et madame
bachelot red sea est donc jeu comme je
n'arrive pas à totalement identifié le
but de ce changement de gouvernement
j'ai un peu de mal à comprendre où il va
mais quand même je crois savoir que il
va continuer la même politique c'est
tous les messages qui ont été envoyées
sont ceux là on va avoir le président a
pris un avocat pour
un ténor pour préparer l'élection
présidentielle
et puis une femme de cultures très bien
tant mieux
voilà mais bon je ne va pas nous amener
à une raison c'est que quand on change
de premier ministre on change un peu de
politique
là c'est pas le cas est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cela alors darcos il n'y a
pas vraiment de réorientation avec ce
nouvel os gouvernement jean castex
non c'est je suis d'accord avec ma
collègue s'est on tourne un petit peu
enfin on fait un jeu de un jeu de
chaises musicales avec en effet quand
même des personnalités fortes qui rentre
là moi je vais être encore plus cynique
je pense qu'en fait c'est forte
personnalité ça peut être aussi de la
part de notre présent à un public une
façon de pouvoir masquer la réalité de
ce qui va se passer en crise économique
et social à la rentrée avec des gens qui
vont occuper beaucoup vos collègues
chers amis parce que forcément il va y
avoir 6 et ça que des gens très
médiatique et donc du coup je dis pas
forcément les clash mais ce sont des
gens qui vont alimenter bien évidemment
les médias et j'espère que ce n'est pas
pour masquer la réalité
avec en plus un bémol par rapport au
premier ministre précédent
non j'ai beaucoup d'affection pour jean
castex est vrai que c'est quelqu'un qui
venait de ma famille politique
simplement comme premier signal de se
voir imposer son directeur de cabinet et
son chef de cabinet par l'elysée a quand
même l'impression que les locales pas
les refus il exactement on a
l'impression qu'il est un peu sous
l'oeil de moscou sous l'oeil de moscou
certains disent également jean marc
gabouty que c'est un peu 50 nuance de
droite ce gouvernement qu'est ce que
vous en pensez à notamment avec camille
pascal l'ex conseiller de nicolas
sarkozy jugent que et bien il ya un peu
l'ensemble des droites dans ce
gouvernement ne crois pas que ce soit un
problème de positionnement politique moi
je peux tout à fait d'accord avec avec
mes collègues même si leurs réflexions
peuvent être à certains égards
pertinente
je pense que je pense qu'il y avait un
peu neuneu parce que je pense plutôt
d'augmenter ce qu'est ce qu'elles ont
dit je pense qu'il y avait malgré tout
un peu d'usure
parce que c'est un gouvernement le
premier ministre est en première ligne
quelles que soient ses capacités c'est
vrai que dans une politique qui était la
sienne je pense que quelqu'un qui est un
qui respecte et qui bien tenues qui est
bien tenu la barre mais vous avez eu
quand même un forme de mouvements
sociaux liés à la réforme la sncf à la
réforme des retraites les gilet jaune la
crise du coc vide
aucun premier ministre auparavant je
dirais n'a été confronté à autant de
difficultés donc mais dans ces parties
très populaire sur des très populaires
oui mais c'est bien qu'ils en sortent
populaire parce que sinon voilà un don
qu'il en est sorti très populaire il ya
peut-être un petit peu d'usure ce qui
était vrai aussi pour le 1 le ministre
de l'intérieur qui était parfois
excessivement critiquer de manière un
petit peu un petit peu injuste une
méthode dont on sentait dont on sentait
quand même aussi je dirais l'usure est
une forme de perte de crédibilité parce
que c'était une tâche excessivement
difficile donc je crois qu'il a mise en
place d'un gouvernement pragmatique je
ne crois pas que les deux ministres
médiatique que vous avez évoquées au
culte parce que la réalité va revenir au
premier plan la réalité ce sont là la
difficulté les difficultés liées à la
crise économique est forcément social
que nous risquons d'avoir à l'automne et
qui va être difficile à gérer donc il
faudra beaucoup de pragmatisme
j'espère que ce premier ministre juste
un mot pour dire que étant un élu local
il ya eu des fonctions locales au
département maire de la ville d'eu de
prades à côté d'eux
son expérience je dirais plus
technocratique ida se voit là il y la
solide à ce véhicule et locales et
j'espère que dans la loi sur la
décentralisation
ça sera un apport positif pour la
politique du gouvernement qui espère
beaucoup avant lui jean marc ayrault
paix avant lui françois fillon c'est à
dire que en fait les premiers ministres
sont toujours des élus locaux dans la
vème république il faut remonter loin
pour en trouver un qui n'était pas élu
local m6 peut être pierre mauroy en 81
donc je crois pas que ce soit une carte
un caractère discriminant que d'être un
élu local dans l'histoire de la vème
république mais bon on va rejoindre les
rues jetant philippe moinet pour vous et
d'accueil signal envoyé par par ce
gouvernement est bien le signale d'abord
merci pour votre invitation pour évoquer
effectivement cette cette conjoncture
politique de très intenses finalement
aller au delà les on va dire des jauges
de et de droite et de gauche et et deux
centres écologistes on pourra y revenir
mais chacun peut avoir un avis
évidemment est légitimement différents
ce qui me frappe dans l'accélération du
de l'agenda politique c'est qu'on est
dans un contexte qui concerne l'opinion
publique en général totalement différent
en tout cas grandement différent par
rapport à ce que nous vivions où il ya
encore trois ou quatre mois rappelons
nous donc il ya une crise historique son
plan sanitaire qui débouche sur une
crise économique et sociale qui risque
d'être historique le premier ministre at
il tort sur ce point on ne pense pas
malheureusement à savoir que ce serait
la crise économique et sociale la plus
grave depuis 1929
en tout cas depuis 1945 c'est sûr et
donc il ya un enjeu nouveau qui n'a
échappé à personne et sans doute pas au
président de la république
emmanuel macron qu'ils considèrent à
tort ou à raison mais qu'il faut
accélérer s'ils les données politiques
et donc changer le premier ministre qui
était encore il ya trois quatre jours
pas du tout comme une évidence
l'accélération et thèse c'est que jean
castex et dans un costume qui est déjà
d'actualité en on n'oublie pas les
qualités et défauts d'edouard philippe
m'enfin l'actualité va très vite et un
gouvernement qui a changé partiellement
avec la sortie de
lyon faible on va dire ou considérés à
tort ou à raison faibles à savoir
christophe castaner notamment et
d'autres qui sont sortis du gouvernement
pour être remplacé par des maillons
considéré à tort ou à raison comme des
maillons forts à savoir deux
personnalités populaires
roselyne bachelot issu des rangs de la
droite et dupond moretti là le ténor un
peu de tonitruants de du bahot le pari
qui est plutôt de sensibilité de gauche
et puis l'arrivée de gérald darmanin on
pourra y revenir pour avoir une analyse
un peu précises de son origine à la fois
sociale et son origine politique ancien
proche du théâtre actuel proche de
nicolas sarkozy est proche de xavier
bertrand
on va on parle ayant effectivement on
est ensemble encore pendant au moins une
demi-heure mais pour compléter ce tour
de table on va d'abord rejoindre
alexandre poussard salle des conférences
car vous êtes avec aussi un sénateur de
la république en marche vous êtes avec
didier rambaud avec didier rambaud aux
sénateurs de la république en marche
issu des rangs du parti socialiste alors
didier rambaud
je vous pose la question est ce que ce
nouveau gouvernement pense trop à droite
très franchement justement je viens du
parti socialiste mais pour moi ce n'est
plus une préoccupation de l'an passé
c'est de compter le nombre de ministres
de savoir de quel parti ils viennent non
je crois que le plus important c'est ce
qui nous attendent devant nous et pour
les prochaines semaines les prochains
mois comment on va on va redresser
économiquement notre pays donc pour vous
le fait qu'il y ait des anciens fidèles
sarkozystes renforcer dans ce
gouvernement c'est pas un problème
je salue d'abord le choix du premier
ministre effectivement avec une
personnalité atypique avec son style
particulier et être longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas eu un premier ministre issu
des territoires comme on dit si bien ici
aux oraux sénat c'est pas un premier
ministre de paris qui regardent la
province mais plutôt un premier ministre
de sa province qui j'espère va va
secouer un petit peu paris et donc vous
saluer également la composition de ce
nouveau gouvernement
il ya des personnalités différentes je
vous trouve très complémentaires
effectivement on m'avait pas encore posé
la question mais l'arrivée de dupond
moretti et quelque chose aussi de je
trouve assez particulier qui me rappelle
d'ailleurs le levage était jeune à
l'époque le choix de françois mitterrand
quand il avait pris robert badinter la
justice on entendait à l'époque les
il est même critique et on a vu comment
par la suite badinter a imprimé le
ministère de justice
donc je suis convaincu que dupont
moretti va être dans le même sens donc
pour vous il ya un intérêt à faire
rentrer au gouvernement des
personnalités médiatiques comme eric
dupond-moretti comme roselyne bachelot
pour attirer l'attention
il faut un petit peu je pense que
d'abord eu ces personnes là ont de
l'expérience donc ça ça compte aussi
elles vont être complémentaire avec
d'autres membres de ce gouvernement qui
sont beaucoup plus jeunes issus de la
société civile donc c'est bien cette
complémentarité entre expérience et
nouveauté
alors quand on regarde le fond au-delà
des personnes et on quand on regarde les
réformes à venir
la réforme des retraites va être remis
sur la table et notamment la partie de
l' équilibre financier du régime des
retraites avec une concertation qui
s'ouvre avant le 20 juillet c'était une
bonne chose de remettre sur la table
cette réforme des retraites je crois
d'abord la première question je crois
que le pays a besoin de faire cette
réforme de retraites on va pas encore
faire comme nos prédécesseurs
la reporter donc il faut il faut là il
faut là effectivement la remettre sur la
table alors est-ce qu'il faut repartir
sur les mêmes bases que que c'est ce qui
a été voté en mars dernier à l'assemblée
nationale je pense pas ça certainement
qu'il faut qu'elle soit beaucoup plus
compréhensible beaucoup plus
pédagogiques mais les principes de base
de cette retraite mais un système plus
universel un système de retraite à
points
ce sont les effectivement autour ces
deux piliers qui va falloir continuer à
travailler et en sortie de cette crise
sanitaire il faut demander aux français
de travailler plus longtemps pour
équilibrer le régime
il faut oui j'ai besoin de plus de
travail c'est évident pour effectivement
on peut il faut beaucoup plus de
productivité de production pour pouvoir
mieux répartir ensuite les richesses et
et embaucher davantage de citoyens dans
notre pays très bien avec ce nouveau
gouvernement on va travailler plus pour
sortir de la crise merci beaucoup et
didier rambaud pour votre intervention
merci beaucoup alexandre on retrouve
tout à l'heure on va rentrer un petit
peu dans le détail de ce gouvernement
bien sûr la première nouveauté et merci
le nouveau premier ministre jean castex
leur entraîneur qu'est ce que vous
inspirez bien ce cette personnalité jean
castex qui a affiché à la couleur du
respect du parlement
et a parlé de lui comme de l'homme des
territoires c'est convaincant c'est pas
très original surtout j'ai jamais vu un
premier ministre se présenter devant le
parlement en disant alors vous je vous
préviens je méprise parlement et j'ai
pas l'intention de vous de dialoguer
avec vous donc c'est un discours
extrêmement contenu convenu pardon
discours très convenue l'homme des
territoires oui bon faut maintenant
parler territoire on dirait comme si les
territoires était une orientation
politique
les territoires c'est la france c'est la
république qu'il parle de la république
et de l'égalité les toits qu'ils sont
c'est pas toujours senti très entendu
parler de la république et de l'égalité
des citoyens dans la république et
d'égalité d'accès aux services publics
qu'on parle des élus locaux de la mairie
on les écoute
bref pour le moment je regarde ce
nouveau premier ministre je le trouve
pas pas différent de bien d'autres que
j'ai vu avant lui et je sais et j'ai
appris que c'était un usage qu on
évaluer les premiers ministres et pas
simplement dans les 48 premières heures
alors bon en tout cas pour l'instant ce
que l'on a de lui un pendant ces 48
première heures s'est notamment et bien
sa première intervention lors des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement à
l'assemblée nationale vous avez suivi ça
pour nous steve alors comment ça s'est
passé pour le premier ministre il
épreuve du feu pour jean castex première
intervention dans la fosse aux lions
première intervention dans l'antre de la
démocratie française alors on a senti un
premier ministre plutôt détendu un pas
franchement impressionné par l'instant
ni par les questions des députés il
avait le débit relativement lent des
réponses plutôt très général pas
d'annoncé évidemment particulière on
attend vous le savez le grand discours
de politique générale ce grand discours
il doit intervenir normalement la
semaine prochaine jean castex a présenté
les grandes lignes de son nouveau
gouvernement écouter la toute première
intervention du tout nouveau premier
ministre dans l'hémicycle c'était tout à
l'heure avec les valeurs qui sont les
miennes
j'ai l'honneur j'ai l'honneur de diriger
ce gouvernement qui sera un gouvernement
de combat qui sera un gouvernement
tourné vers l'efficacité qui sera un
gouvernement de dialogue qui sera un
gouvernement des territoires
voilà autre point intéressant de cette
séance de questions au gouvernement
c'est la réforme des retraites on s'en
rappelle elle avait été suspendue au
moment de la crise sanitaire elle
revient sur la pointe des pieds depuis
quelques semaines emmanuel macron l'a
promis elle ne sera pas abandonner
c'était aujourd'hui au tour de jean
castex de l'évoquer une réforme qui sera
selon lui plus juste pour tous les
français écoutent et il a d'ores et déjà
était acté que nous distingue riom les
concertations à reprendre sur la réforme
de forme à laquelle nous ne renoncerons
pas sur un système de retraites plus
juste plus juste
cattin de leurs voeux tous les français
voilà sur cette réforme des retraites le
calendrier est extrêmement serré jean
castex de rencontrer les partenaires
sociaux avant la fin du mois le premier
ministre entend remettre tout le monde à
la table des négociations pour une
réforme prévue à la rentrée mais la cfdt
et le medef sont pour leur opposer un
calendrier aussi rapide on l'aura
compris cette réforme des retraites ce
sera sans doute le premier dossier
explosif du tout nouveau premier
ministre tam
merci beaucoup steve donc pas encore de
discours de politique générale mais on
n'en sait quand même plus sur la réforme
des retraites et on retient que eh bien
il tient à cette réforme jean castex et
que dans un premier temps eh bien il va
surtout s'occuper des questions
budgétaires puisqu'il appelle à résoudre
et bien ce problème de façon urgente et
il appelle à une réunion avant le 20
juillet alors langue abuser non plus une
question budgétaire là on est un je
dirais dans des abîmes qui sont
profondes
c'est pas uniquement budgétaire c'est
économique et social parce qu'on est à
l'heure parce que la politique du
gouvernement
pour amortir effectivement l'arrêt
d'activité trop large d'ailleurs au
moment du commis de 19
les mesures prises ont joué un rôle
d'amortisseur c'est à dire qu'on retarde
un petit peu l'échéance on permet à des
entreprises qui auraient chuté tout de
suite le chômage qui s'est envolé
immédiatement d'avoir d'avoir un clip de
dd pour faire un plan de relance pour
redémarrer et c'est donc c'est bien mais
je dirais la grosse difficulté
économique l aider à l'horizon du mois
de septembre et du mois de du mois
d'octobre la réforme des retraites c'est
autre chose mais le problème numéro un
c'est celui ci parce que je crois que
les prévisions de chômage
oui il a raison de le dissocier de la
réforme structurelle au niveau des
retraites
oui au niveau des retraites ils disent
aussi clairement la question
structurelle le système universel et
puis la question financier moi moi
j'étais soutien de la réforme des
retraites avec quand même je dirais un
favorable également un certain nombre de
remarques et propositions de certains
syndicats comme l'unsa et la cfdt par
darcos
oui alors là dessus je pense que avec ma
collègue on attendra quand même de pied
ferme le gouvernement nous avions
commencé avant le confinement à
travailler sur un rapport sur les
retraites des femmes avec la délégation
aux droits des femmes et je peux vous
dire là dessus
il ya unanimité chez nous mais j'allais
dire même chez les partenaires sociaux
pour dire que le système annoncé est
particulièrement injuste pour les femmes
et qu'il faut prendre en compte encore
les 25 meilleures années et non pas
l'ensemble de la carrière
professionnelle pour elle donc on est
assez content d'une certaine manière
qu'on pourra remettre norap notre
rapport est la discussion sur
voilà ce sur le feu parce que
honnêtement là dessus je pense que on à
être entendu est ce que je peux dire
aujourd'hui revenir sur le paradoxe
enfin je trouve assez aberrant et on est
tous finalement aussi amnésique les uns
que les autres
il ya quinze jours nous avions un
présent un public qui nous présentait
150 personnes soit 10 ans tirée au sort
pour nous présenter les réformes à venir
du gouvernement
doyenne pour le climat voilà et les
réformes pour le pays et les réformes à
venir
et là en fait bon voilà nouveau
gouvernement un premier ministre des
territoires
on revient à des sujets qui étaient
prévus depuis longtemps et moi je trouve
qu en effet dans un quinquennat c'est
tellement court qu'il faut revenir en
effet aux priorités
on s'est fixé dans un quinquennat donc
tant mieux parce que je voyage avait été
extrêmement choqué et je pense que ça a
beaucoup joué pour le deuxième tour et
que une certaine manière le présent
avait obliqué responsable de la du
dégagisme et de l'absentéisme au
deuxième tour parce que quand on se
nomme et qu'on méprise à ce point la
représentation la démocratie
représentative et que c'est des gens
tiraient au sort qui doivent décider du
sort de notre pays
je pense que ça participe au fait que
les élus sont galvaudés voire méprisée
donc heureusement là on revient à
quelque chose d'un schéma beaucoup plus
classique
là c'est étonnant que voilà le premier
ministre entre canon n'ai pas encore
parlé que peut-être du coup ça va être
une fois de plus des projets qu'on
mettra bien sous le tapis la vente
raciale car il affiche très clairement
la priorité et vous au contraire vous
demander le report de la réforme de
retrouver station totalement
irresponsable de la part de passe dans
la république et du premier ministre que
se donner comme objectif de finir par
faire passer la réforme des retraites
dont personne ne veut personne n'en
voulait et personne n'en veut toujours
de cette réforme des retraites quand on
connaît l'état encaissera le pays quand
on peut anticiper ça a été évoqué il ya
un instant après les amortisseurs
c'est-à-dire à l'automne en terme de
chômage de précarité
difficultés collectives comme s'ils
perry pays n'allait pas suffisamment
souffrir il faut en plus infliger au
pays
une réforme dont personne ne veut mais
ce gouvernement de combat c'est un
gouvernement de combat contre des
français quand même avant tout avant
d'être le gouvernement de combat pour
les laisser entrer en scène 2022
médiamat qu'on parle d'un gouvernement
de rassemblement
vous trouvez que c'est faux c'est
totalement contradictoire de d'afficher
une volonté de rassemblement et de
remettre sur la table la réforme des
retraites dont chacun sait qu'elle pose
tellement de problèmes et par ailleurs
des réformes des retraites je peux
entendez tout à l'heure le sénateur
macro nist la capic s'est exprimé avec
nous informe direct en a une il y en a
une de marisol touraine et une de
françois fillon c'est dire qu'on a eu
deux réforme des retraites autour des
deux précédents quinquennat et nous
sommes nombreux à dire que cette
réforme-là n'est pas nécessaire si ce
n'est si ce n'est pour baisser le niveau
des retraites toujours l'objectif cette
réforme et les français l'ont très bien
compris
philippe jean philippe moinet comment
est ce que vous vous réagissez bien se
signale cet affichage sur la réforme des
retraites alors que et bien on avait dit
pendant un temps que c'était vraiment
pas le moment d'aborder un sujet aussi
clivant et finalement on voit qu'il est
immédiatement et bien sûr le sur le
devant de la scène ce sujet oui c'est
vrai que c'est un sujet qui est qui
revient pour une raison à la fois
conjoncturelles et structurelles
la raison conjoncturelle n'est pas
secondaire non plus hein c'est vrai
qu'il ya un plongeon de 4 milliards pour
perspective d'avant la crise kobe de
déficit du système actuel de retraite à
30 milliards pour l'année 2020 donc il y
à un sujet qui est d'actualité qui est
celui alors c'est le terme employé par
le premier ministre jean castex
sauvegarder photos sauvegardées doit-on
il
damman sa réponse est oui sauvegarder le
système actuel pour combler ce déficit
qui se rajouterait rappelons le un des
visites qui s'est creusé pour atteindre
pour l'ensemble du pays 118 120 % du pib
donc on est dans une situation difficile
de ce point de vue là budgétairement
parlant aussi le sujet des la
concertation sociale annoncée puisque le
premier ministre en castex invoque son
gaullisme social c'est son terme
et puis le le sujet de la concertation
tout
azimut avec les partenaires sociaux et
avec les territoires
il a annoncé pour dit il c'était sa
première expression télévisée chez vos
confrères de tf1 pour un nouveau pacte
social basé sur à la fois les
partenaires sociaux et les territoires
va-t-il réussir ce grand paris le
gaulliste on peut imaginer que les
oppositions en doute mais c'est aussi le
coeur du logiciel que lui veut imprimer
dans cette période est juste un mot pour
évoquer quand même l'innovation de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat on
verra ce qu'il en viendra leur darcos
évoqué un certain scepticisme sur
l'application de cette mesure dans la de
cette méthode dans la durée le président
de la république
emmanuel macron annoncé quand même le
lendemain des élections municipales que
non seulement la convention citoyenne
pour le climat seraient réunies et ses
citoyens seront réunis par le
gouvernement pour eux pour assurer
l'application des 146 mesure sur 149
proposé mais il l'a annoncé est ce qu'il
le fera on verra mais enfin il a annoncé
cette innovation démocratique quand même
qui pose question mais lucide qui trace
les perspectives de réunir une
convention citoyenne sur d'autres sujets
qui peuvent être peut-être on verra des
sujets sociaux
en tout cas c'est un logiciel qui fait
intervenir un mode de démocratie
participative ou plutôt délibérative qui
par ses propositions qui seront intégrés
par le parlement ou pas allez y enverra
et par le gouvernement quand ce sont des
mesures de type réglementaire donc c'est
un site un système quand même nouveaux
skis a pas beaucoup été commentées mais
qui à mon avis a son importance dans
cette troisième séquence du quinquennat
pour accréditer l'idée qu'il faut
restaurer une confiance envers les
politiques en général et peut y avoir
toute opposition égales par ailleurs une
alliance objective de tous ceux qui
veulent restaurer l'image des politiques
et se rapprocher des citoyens
c'est un pari qui concerne tout le monde
qu'il soit dans l'opposition ou dans la
majorité
oui votre réaction lors darcos ça vous
fait réagir et puis on passe au reste du
monde en échange
jean-philippe on en reparlera tous les
deux si tu veux mais en effet
c'est sur le choix de que ça soit 150
personnes
je suis patient plus totalement entriez
au hasard qu'ils puissent décider du
sort des réformes
je pense qu'il y assez aujourd'hui de
responsabilité 22 jan en responsabilité
par même de comité scientifique de
comité d'association sur le climat sur
l'environnement qui pouvait tout à fait
et c'est aussi le rôle du cscs ce qui
pouvait discuter de tout ça plus que des
citoyens qui vont du coup d'une certaine
manière pour jeter l'opprobe sur renault
a stabilisé ses cordes archos la
concertation la consultation avec les
partenaires sociaux les aigles monde
associatif oui ensuite l'instauration
d'une démocratie du tirage au sort s'est
pas vraiment je dirais mon idée
personnelle ça fait ça fait débat on va
continuer on va poursuivre en parlant du
reste du gouvernement parce que vous
l'avez dit il ya des figures médiatiques
qui attire beaucoup l'attention et bien
des médias le retour à la politique de
la désormais très cathodique roselyne
bachelot et puis aussi l arrivée à la
tête du ministère de la justice du ténor
du barreau eric dupont-moretti sa
première prise de parole tout à l'heure
aux questions d'actualité a été un petit
peu hésitante face et bien au bruit
qu'il y a dans l'hémicycle l'ajlnh ont
néanmoins eu droit à une
standing-ovation écoutez vous savez tous
que quand on est avocat pénaliste libre
on n'a pas la même parole que quand on
représente l'état ça n'échappe à
personne
avez vous toujours dit la même chose
c'est vrai qu'à un moment j'ai dit que
je n'accepterais pas cette tâche toi tu
y avoir une dizaine ou une quinzaine
d'années on va mettre un terme définitif
non le jeu vous en prie le sait déjà
c'est déjà compliqué pour moi c'est là
c'est une première
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'oubli laissez moi
monsieur le député j'ai un sens aigu du
contradictoire et du respect de la
parole de l'autre j'aimerais que vous me
laissiez au moins m'exprimer au
pardonnez moi on ne juge
on ne les monsieur le député je voudrais
vous répondre complètement
on ne juge pas des hommes sur des a
priori me semble-t-il
vous me jugerez sur ce que j'ai fait
quand je leur ai fait et pardonnez moi
pardonnez moi vous je vais vous dire
quelque chose quand on est haut quand on
est au café du commerce on ne s'exprime
pas l'or comme quand on est avocat
quand on est avocat on ne s'exprime pas
comme quand on est ministre ça c'est
pour la forme
moi au 15 mai au café du commerce je ne
porte pas de cravate à l'assemblée jean
mais une bon là étonnant de voir ce
ténor du barreau face 20 dans la fosse
aux lions 1 disiez vous vous avez connu
dans cette situation laurence rossignol
c'est impressionnant vous vous comprenez
le trouble du nouveau garde des sceaux
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
ben c'est son baptême du feu voilà donc
là aujourd'hui bénéficie encore de
descent d'innovation' de sa majorité il
les aura pas à chaque fois
et puis le faire qu'après on rentre dans
le vif du sujet c'est quelle type de
garde des sceaux va-t-il être le fond à
ce que j'entends la comparaison avec
robert badinter
je la trouve amitié aussi aux élèves des
avocats n'ont émis des quantités des
gardes des sceaux avocat j'ai trop
imposer robert badinter était là avec
une feuille de route l'abolition de la
peine de mort c'est quoi
l'équivalent de l'abolition de la peine
de mort pour eric dupond-moretti je ne
sais pas on connaît pas sa feuille de
route c'est toute la différence avec
robert badinter elle est énorme
laure darcos qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire cette nomination est bien de
d'eric dupond-moretti on a déjà aussi vu
et bien le les boucliers enlevé par les
l'union syndicale des magistrats qui
parle de déclaration de guerre car eric
dupond moretti a eu des mots très durs à
un gars notamment du parquet national
financier en parlant d'une clique de
juges qui s'autorise tout écoutez je ne
connais pas particulièrement c'est pas
mes sujets je trouve que c'est bien
jouer enfin je pense qu'en effet il ya
trois semaines on devrait nous en aurait
parlé mais même lui d'ailleurs sur les
on disait jamais au grand jamais comme
comme aux innocents pourquoi c'est très
drôle mais je trouve que c'est plutôt
bien joué après en effet je suis
d'accord avec avec laurence quelle sera
sa veuve sa feuille de route il faut
plaire en même temps aux magistrats en
même temps voilà enfin on n'est pas que
un avocat avec un costard de deux
ministres
donc j'attends de voir mais si vous me
permettez ce que je passe j'aurai
d'autres la parole anna nouveau mais moi
c'est ce qui m'a fait plaisir c'est la
nomination de roselyne parce qu'en fait
je raconter une petite anecdote c'était
mon premier boss quand j'avais 22 ans et
juppé nous avait chargé en 92-93 de
parler des femmes parlait pas encore de
parité mais les femmes en politique
et pour la petite anecdote c'est qu'on
appelait les magazines féminins pour
essayer de parler des femmes en
politique et à chaque fois au standard
on faisait voulait la rubrique mode la
rubrique e santé etc et on sait jamais
plus quitté
et je peux vous dire vrai manque en
effet si elle revient c'est vraiment
parce que ses émissaires de la juste de
la cud a gracié jamais eu
malheureusement on se croise dans tous
les festivals chaque année est donc pour
elle je suis très heureuse et j'espère
qu'elle réussira et je suis quand même
content que franck riester n'est pas été
dégagés complètement parce que ils
n'avaient pas démérité et du coup je
content qu'il est chaud s'est passé je
sais mais il avait quand même des
députés agir erreur lui jean marc
gabouty surtout sur eric dupond moretti
d'abord parce que vous inspire c'est
très bien parce que ça malgré que
progressèrent n'est pas démérité sa
demande est un petit peu plus d'empathie
un petit peu voilà je crois qu'il ya pas
plus d'incarnation est là elle a une
personnalité qui correspond mieux
je dirais à ce ministère eric
dupond-moretti moi je n'ai je n'ai pas
d'avis je le connais en tant que femme
je le vois en tant qu'avocat avocat
pénaliste où souvent on est on se dit
comment peut-il défendre des causes de
ce si c'est comme cette crèche geste et
français alors en même temps il ya le
caractère brillant ce quelqu'un
d'intelligent et c'est moi je
voilà j'espère qu'il va qu'il va réussir
parce que c'est l'intérêt du pays ses
intérêts du gouvernement bien sûr mais
je n'ai pas de je n'ai pas d'à priori je
n'ai pas de certitude le président de la
république a fait un pari un père qu'ils
espèrent qu'il doit eurent raison de
faire ce pari mais je ne m'en fais ça
casse je n'en suis pas totalement
persuadé
oui je m'interroge sur les raisons pour
laquelle le président république a
choisi de nommer eric dupond moretti
eric dupond moretti et je ne juge jamais
un avocat sur le choix de ses clients
sur ses clients et sur ce qui est dit
dans les plaidoiries le droit de la
défense justifie qu'un avocat plaide
comme il veut en revanche eric dupond
moretti a pris de nombreuses positions
en fait correspond à un cours en
français pas marin pas majorité un mec
existe c'est celui qui dit on peut plus
dragué on peut plus rigoler on peut
faire de plaisanteries sur les femmes
on peut plus conduire la voiture à la
vitesse qu'on veut on peut fumer où on
veut en fait c'est tout ce courant qui
on retrouve d'ailleurs dans beaucoup de
pays populiste sur les libertés
individuelles contre les protections
collectives et comme je sais que
emmanuel macron est très préoccupée
d'avoir face à lui en 2022 un candidat
populiste un candidat qui viendraient
justement de ce courant là je me demande
s'il n'a pas embauché dupond-moretti
pour faire sont populistes à lui oui
c'est ce que je voudrais ville harris
est très bon à la gîte pour vous c'est
oui c'est très urgent parce que je sais
je ne me demande si le but n'est pas de
donner des gages au populisme et je peux
pas empêcher de penser quand même que
quand on met au ministère de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin mis en cause dans une
affaire de viol encore devant la justice
aujourd'hui plus mises en cause dans une
autre affaire cassez ensuite mais dont
l'effet reste les faits sont là il a été
mis en cause pour mes du d'innocence a
répondu jean castex
mais la présomption d'innocence
n'empêche pas qu'il est suspect cette
présomption est ce que vous avez vu la
présomption d'innocence
lorsqu'il s'agit des homards de françois
de rugy ou de tous les autres ministres
qui étaient pris dans des affaires
politico financières
ils ont fait leurs bagages du
gouvernement deux temps trois mouvements
ce que je comprends c'est pas que c'est
la présomption d'innocence ce que je
comprends c'est qu aux yeux de ce
gouvernement
les violences sexuelles et les atteintes
sexuelles sont moins
rave que toutes les autres infractions
on se débarrasse d'un ministre qui a
mangé du maroc à l'hôtel de lassay
mais on garde un ministre qui mise en
cause dans une affaire de viol parce que
si la présomption d'innocence pour
autant les faits sont là lorna face-off
sur les violences sexuelles est ce que
vous pensez vous aussi que sont la
personne et je suis là aussi peut-être
ça va choquer laurence présention et
chance il est déjà il a été innocenté
enfin on ne peut pas non plus savoir
exactement ce qu'ils ne sentent l
affaire a été rouverte réouverte
non mais parce que mon chien excuse moi
alors comment on va faire comment vont
faire les policiers qui vont ainsi
qu'ils vont enquêter sur cette affaire
l'enquêté ouverte il n'y a pas eu de
confrontation entre le mis en cause est
la plaignante la confrontation devrait
avoir lieu comment il faut faire les
policiers pour enquêter sur un ministre
de l'intérieur mis en cause dans une
affaire que vaut la parole de la
plaignante contre la parole du ministre
mis en cause il ne devrait pas être à
cette place là temps que cette affaire
n'est pas admis ni juger définitivement
or il est et c'est un signal terrible
qui est envoyé aux femmes
ça veut dire en fait vous pouvez
toujours aller porter plainte vous
pouvez toujours dire tout ce que vous
voulez au bout du compte
celui que vous mettez en cause ça
n'empêche pas d'être ministre de
l'intérieur jean philippe moinet votre
votre votre réaction sur ce que pense
laurence rossignol de et bien ce casting
gouvernemental et est ce que c'est un
mauvais signal donné aux femmes alors
sur eric dupond-moretti d'abord je suis
plutôt d'accord avec mme rossignol sur
le sujet de du populaire un tantinet
populiste qui est je rejoins aussi et
j'aurais concilie ses deux sénatrices
laure darcos pour dire que c'est pas un
mauvais coup de ce point de vue c'est
qu'il y à la fois il est il est en rade
heroes borderline sur certains sujets je
suis d'accord sur la question au mythe
où il a surfé aussi sur une réactivité
française à des dérives de procès
d'intention rapide sur les réseaux
sociaux pour pour certaines choses qui
ont pu être commises mais le pu être
commise c'est de la justice quand même
avec la sérénité qu'il faut de de
trancher et donc sur dupond-moretti je
pense qu'il ya un effet
dix nominations populaire inattendu qui
peut servir aux delà de la question de
la justice qu'il connaît très bien quand
même alors certes d'un point de vu
d'avocat mais connaît parfaitement quand
même les rouages de la maison ministère
de la justice et l'usagé qui peut en
être fait par le présent la république
et manuel mâcon car on est évidemment à
20 mois des élections présidentielles
c'est que en cas de besoin il pourrait
être dans les renforts direct en défense
ou en eau en offensive d'ailleurs sur
certains sujets au profit de la majorité
présidentielle actuelle sur gérald
darmanin
c'est un autre sujet me semble-t-il même
si la question liée au féminisme est
aussi présente
il ya eu à la fois il faut le rappeler
quand même une information judiciaire
ouverte précédemment en 2018 où il était
déjà ministre ait été entendu qui a fait
l'objet d'un classement sans suite comme
on dit non lieu il ya plaignante a voulu
porter à faire appel ce qui a fait son
droit est totalement légitime
d'où la deuxième information judiciaire
là c'est vrai que ça fragilise
relativement ne ça fragilise quand même
ce nouveau ministre de l'intérieur qui
par ailleurs a été choisi pour des
raisons politiques très précises venant
de l air comme on le sait venant de
cette amitié avec nicolas sarkozy qui
est plus ou moins actualisé et aussi par
la proximité qu'il a avec les aviez
bertrand lui l'élu de haute france à la
tête d'une mairie
tourcoing balle au pied dans l'univers
géographique de dinde et potentiel
candidat à la présidence de la
république venant de l'univers et l'ère
où excellait récurrence pour xavier
bertrand puisqu'il a quitté ce mouvement
politique comme d'ailleurs valérie
pécresse
donc il ya il ya un jeu à la fois
politique et puis des éléments de
fragilité qu'il faut pas sous-estimer il
faut pas non plus les les surestimer
même si politiquement l'opposition
notamment de gauche peut exploiter cette
faille
il nous reste juste une minute pour
conclure ce débat
en un mot qu'est ce que vous attendez
vous en tout cas et bien des dix mois
qui suivent que doit faire le
gouvernement cadre est pour vous et sa
priorité
laurence rossignol d'abord la priorité
va être au social et à l'économique
redresser le pays
ramener l'industrie en france et
répondre à la demande sociale qui va
être extrêmement important et élever
importante et puis aussi moraliser la
vie politique ce que j'observe qu'il
n'ait pas fait ça avait été promis en
2017 gepi de ne pas croire toutes les
promesses j'ai eu raison la matière
parce que je trouve la vie politique
assez immoral
depuis que ce nouveau gouvernement était
nommé et d ignaux français vaste
programme
laure darcos vos priorités pour l'avenir
mes priorités alors sont beaucoup les
mêmes que ma collègue la rentrée va être
extrêmement importante et est très
inquiétante donc crise sociale et crise
économique
et je pense que les faillites notamment
d'entreprises ne vont arriver qu'en fin
d'année
et puis mon dada c'est qu'en effet
peut-être que ce gouvernement puisse
remettre les parlementaires et les élus
un peu plus en avant un peu plus en
considération
là ce soir on va quand même avoir juste
à voir passer le train de directives
européennes extrêmement importantes
comme le smda et le droit d'auteur y
aura juste demandé de donner une
habitation d'ordonnancé un peu plus de
poids pour le parlement dans l'année qui
viennent on est plus jeune et tendance
pour la france un souhait partagé
j'imagine à jean marc gabouty je serai
pas original à aux dix ans que j'ai
dites leur que la priorité c'est le
redressement économique et social parce
que même si l'économie arrive à se
redresser correctement sur le plan
social il durera non pas un million de
chômeurs supplémentaires mais
probablement deux ou trois donc voilà
donc il ya un problème
je dirais important essentiel et
derrière regarder quand même à mieux
travailler avec les collectivités
locales des régions les départements les
intercommunalités des communes parce
qu'on a bien vu que sur le plan
opérationnel c'était des échelons qui
était peut être plus efficace dans la
crise du coït certains
approvisionnements c'est là que les
services notamment les attendra de voir
les actes merci beaucoup à tous les
cadres d'avoir participé à ce débat
merci à laurence rossignol merci laure
darcos merci à jean marc gabouty et
merci jean philippe moinet tout de suite
alors que nous sommes à une vingtaine de
minutes du début des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
première question d'actualité du
gouvernement un castex ici au sénat eh
bien on va rejoindre steve jourdain
salle des conférences car vous êtes avec
le sénateur communiste du nord éric
bocquet
oui bonjour eric bocquet jours les
premières questions au gouvernement pour
ce nouveau gouvernement vont débuter
dans maintenant une petite vingtaine de
minutes pour l'instant quelles sont vos
premières impressions sur ce nouveau
gouvernement à écouter et nous enchante
je crois au 42e gouvernement de cette
5ème république depuis 1958 quand j'ai
entendu les noms des ministres égrainé
par monsieur colère vendredi soir j'ai
attendu longtemps à voir avant
d'entendre un nouveau nom mais au delà
du casting c'est le scénario qui
m'inquiète c'est la feuille de route et
les premières interventions du premier
ministre dont je ne conteste pas
l'intelligence et les qualités
personnelles
on est sur la même politique qu'il a il
revient en avant la réforme des
retraites
là on semble hésiter un peu sur
l'allocation chômage voilà justement
peut-être que sur sur cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage
elle devait entrer en vigueur en
septembre elle va finalement être
décalée nous dit on c'est une bonne
chose de la décaler selon vous je crois
que ce gouvernement prend en compte la
réalité psychologique de ce pays le pays
va mal et puis n'oublions pas non plus
qu'il s'est passé un deuxième tour des
municipales où la république en marche
pour le moins raté son ancrage local
c'est moins qu'on puisse dire alors on
tourne vite la page mais il faut quand
même rappeler cette réalité les gens
l'opinion publique a donné son avis sur
la politique menée il ya du
mécontentement il ya eu des luttes sur
la sncf sur les retraites notamment ya
eu les gilet jaune
donc je ne vois pas de signe
annonciateur d'une nouvelle politique
d'une réorientation des lendemains qui
chantent est qu'on nous annonçait il ya
quelques temps les plans sociaux se
multiplient il y en aurait une trentaine
par semaine actuellement selon le
ministère du travail c'est énorme
absolument c'est énorme parce que ces
plans se traduisent par des milliers de
suppressions d'emplois des groupes
énorme des groupes puissants je pense à
sanofi par exemple dont le monsieur paul
hodgson sont son nouveau dirigeant
depuis quelque temps qu'ils disaient il
faut playes tout est en anglais jouaient
pour gagner comme si l'économie c'était
un jeu il s'agit de la vie des gens de
l'économie d'un pays
sanofi a la capacité j'imagine d'engager
des recherches conséquente pour trouver
le vaccin qui réglera ce problème du
comité de la pandémie
au lieu de ça on distribue des
dividendes juteux on reçoit des crédits
d'impôts on bénéficie de la manne
publique et au bout on licencie c'est
encore une fois les salariés qui
trinquent
c'est tout avant intérêts interdire les
licenciements les licenciements
boursiers il faut absolument les
interdire par la loi nous avions déposé
il ya quelques temps une loi dans ce
sens qui n'a pas été retenu mais elle
reste tout à fait d'actualité vous
parlais tout à l'heure de la réforme des
retraites le nouveau gouvernement évoque
la nécessité de reprendre le dialogue il
faut le reprendre ce dialogue selon le
texte actuel dans ce nouveau contexte
ça fait des années qu'on discute sur le
sujet des mois et ce que j'en juge par
la réaction de l'opinion majoritaire
cette réforme de passe-passe cette
réforme ne reçoit pas l'assentiment
majoritaire de l'opinion publique d'où
le blocage qui s'est constituée la le
gouvernement revient à la charge dans un
pays fracture est fragilisée avec de
fortes inégalités avec une forte attente
chez nos concitoyens de protection de
service public de mieux vivre quoi donc
franchement remettre en avant cette
réforme des retraites c'est la pire des
décisions
merci beaucoup éric bocquet d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup steve pour cette
intervention
nous sommes maintenant à un quart
d'heure de la séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
première séance de questions d'actualité
pour ce gouvernement castex jean castex
qui va devoir répondre à beaucoup de
questions cet après midi on va rejoindre
alexandre couche-tard salle des
conférences rejoint donc la carte à
l'autre
alexandre alexandre mais oui
effectivement notamment direct de la
salle des conférences du sénat on attend
dans quelques secondes l'arrivée du
premier ministre jean castex le nouveau
premier ministre chef du gouvernement
qui a marqué depuis quelques jours son
attachement au territoire aux
collectivités locales
d'ailleurs sa première visite
institutionnels c'était ici au sénat à
gérard larcher
il devrait donc recevoir un accueil
plutôt bienveillant de la part de la
haute assemblée surtout que son origine
politique eh bien c'est la droite c'est
la sarkozie donc on va voir comment il
est accueilli ici au sénat par les
sénateurs
oui merci beaucoup alexandrins jean
castex qui répondra au moins à trois
questions puisqu'il est interrogé cet
après-midi par trois présidents de
groupe patrick kanner président du
groupe socialiste sur la politique
générale
eliane assassi la présidente du groupe
communiste sur et bien la réforme des
retraites on en parlait à l'instant sur
ce plateau et le bal des questions sera
ouvert par le président du groupe
centriste au sénat hervé marseille et
qui lui parlera et bien du rôle du
parlement dans la politique
gouvernementale on va tout de suite
c'est bien aller à nouveau dans cette
salle des conférences rejoindre cette
fois ci à steve jourdain
steve vous êtes avec le sénateur et
l'ère jean raymond ligonnet oui jean
raymond urbaine et bonjour merci d'être
avec nous beaucoup d'anciens sarkozyste
beaucoup d'hommes de droit dans ce
gouvernement ça doit vous plaire dans
wii alors pas spécialement pour ça c'est
plutôt drôle de constater que le
président de la république a pris le
pouvoir par la gauche est gouvernée par
la droite et on n'a jamais vu d'ailleurs
autant de sarkozyste dans un
gouvernement même à l'époque de nicolas
sarkozy donc voilà j'ai pour jean castex
une certaine voie la sympathie on sait
que c'est un homme clairement compétent
un homme de devoir qui a des valeurs
voilà bien bien accroché à sa
gouvernance maintenant nous attendons
les mots c'est une chose maintenant il
faut voir il faut lui prêter le crédit
bien sûr la nomination de gérald
darmanin à l'intérieur et dirait d'eric
dupond-moretti à la justice a fait
bondir certaines associations féministes
quelle est votre position sur ce point
alors je pense qu'il ya vraiment deux
fait un petit peu qu'ils sont défaits on
va dire plutôt médiatique dupond moretti
et roselyne bachelot voilà ça c'est pour
un petit peu j'allais dire amuser la
galerie maintenant la vraie nomination
importante c'est celle de gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur ça veut
donc dire que il là il ya un accord
profond scellé avec le président de la
république qui ne peut pas se permettre
de mettre à l'intérieur
quelqu'un qui ne lui soit pas totalement
loyal monsieur castaner avec le respect
que je lui dois été totalement consumés
sur place depuis des mois un mauvais
ministre de l'intérieur selon mauvais
vous savez c'est une place qui est
tellement difficile à je crois une
mission qui est tellement difficile à
remplir que on va pas lui jeter la
pierre il s'est discrédité lui même en
se précipitant devant des micros avant
même de se précipiter sur l'action je
crois qu'il était discrédité auprès des
troupes
c'est une bonne chose en voir christophe
castaner il a voilà il a été ministre de
l'intérieur qu'on le veuille ou non
maintenant gérald darmanin ça va être
une autre affaire et je vois que lors de
sa première sortie il est il avait déjà
il remplissait déjà le costume comme on
dit vous savez donc cette majoration sur
moi vous savez
pour répondre précisément à votre
question dans ce pays il ya quelque
chose qui s'appelle la présomption
d'innocence
et même si c'est quelque chose qui a
disparu des écrans parce que maintenant
on cloue au pilori n'importe qui pour
n'importe quoi
eh bien je dois dire que là dessus je
j'ai confiance toute confiance en eric
dupond-moretti pour qu'il rétablisse un
petit peu ce que c'est que la
véritablement la présomption d'innocence
et je crois qu'il faut l'accord des au
ministre de l'intérieur surtout quand
les premières décisions lui ont été
favorables on disait que ce quinquennat
pour ce quinquennat la grande cause
serait l'égalité entre sexes selon vous
sa n'hypothèque pas l'égalité entre eux
entre sexes hommes femmes
ah oui alors on parle beaucoup de cette
égalité plus on en parle j'ai
l'impression - on l'a fait vous voyez
dans cette société alors c'est les
sujets sociétaux dont on nous rebat les
oreilles c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important la place des
femmes en politique et dans la vie elle
est très importante c'est même elle qui
la donnent la vie donc je crois que
c'est incontournable
maintenant pour ce qui est de la justice
c'est une autre affaire on attend de ce
pays qu'on est on restaure le sentiment
de justice et la confiance en la justice
voilà c'est ce que l'on attend vous
parliez des sujets sociétaux et aussi
des sujets sociaux une actualité sociale
très lourde très chargé sur la réforme
des retraites peut être on n'a pas
vraiment vu on n'a pas du tout vu
d'ailleurs au sénat elle va revenir vous
vous en féliciter vous êtes pour ce
retour de la réforme des retraites façon
macron nous allons voir si le président
de la république a envie de mettre le
feu à ce pays
ou pas notre pays traverse une crise
que l'on n'avait jamais vu jusqu'à
présent aujourd'hui l'heure est à la
reprise au renouveau au rebond appelons
le comme l'on veut mais s'ils nous remet
sur la table des débats qui ont mis le
feu à la société tout simplement parce
qu'ils ont été mal à mener
eh bien j'ai bien peur que le président
de la république récolte ce qui leur à
ce sommet c'est à dire un petit vent de
tempête
merci beaucoup monsieur luis avoir
répondu à mes questions un petit vent de
tempête craint jean raymond hugonnet on
parlait à l'instant de gérald darmanin
sachez qu'il sera interrogé alors de
cette séance de questions d'actualité
par la sénatrice theiler jacqueline
eustache brinio qui est notamment connu
pour avoir relancé le débat sur le voile
et qui va interroger le nouveau ministre
de l'intérieur sur la question de la
laïcité
on continue les interviews salle des
conférences on va rejoindre alexandre
poussard avec stands car vous êtes avec
le vice-président socialiste du sénat le
sénateur de paris david assouline
effectivement tam david assouline qu'est
ce que vous pensez à déjà de la
composition de ce nouveau gouvernement
est ce qu'il pense trop à droite
oui c'est peu de le dire c'est un
gouvernement sarkozy tout simplement
même si nicolas sarkozy n'avait pas osé
nommer autant de sarkozy d'ailleurs
monsieur devedjian s'en était plaint à
l'époque donc j'attends pas beaucoup sur
le plan social sur le plan de tout ce
qui sera nécessaire parce que la crise
économique c'est aussi une crise sociale
ou encore une fois les plus démunis vaut
payer et il fallait donner
le là que c'est ça la priorité hors
clairement c'est pas ça la priorité
j'attends que dans ces questions
d'actualité on puisse voir comment ses
ministres notamment le premier ministre
parle à la représentation nationale
parlement a besoin d'être écouté d'être
respectés et j'attends beaucoup de voir
quel va être le style mais sur le fond
j'ai je n'attends rien je me battrai
comme avant et on va voir si ce nouveau
premier ministre jean castex est
véritablement l écoute des collectivités
territoriales et des sénateurs merci
beaucoup david assouline
oui merci beaucoup alexandre et tout de
suite on va rejoindre steve qui est avec
hervé marseille le président du groupe
centriste à qui je le disais va ouvrir
le bal des questions à dans quelques
minutes
oui monsieur marseille bonjour vous
allez poser la première question à ce
tout nouveau gouvernement ce qui vous
interroge ses les relations quelles
seront les relations entre le parlement
et le gouvernement
effectivement le premier ministre vient
d'être nommé des ministres depuis
simplement quelques heures donc on ne
sait pas quelle va être sa ligne
politique faut attendre que le président
définissent la ligne le 14 juillet alors
ma question sera simple c'est quelles
sont vos priorités et comment
entendez-vous travailler avec le sénat
ces dernières années on peut pas dire
que le sénat était beaucoup associé à
l'action de la politique gouvernementale
alors on va voir
parce que ces relations étaient un peu
dégradée ces derniers temps du grade et
voilà merci beaucoup monsieur marcel je
vous laisse rejoindre l'hémicycle vous
allez être le premier donc à poser cette
question au tout premier gouvernement
castex qui donc assistera à cette
première séance de questions au
gouvernement ici au sénat
oui merci beaucoup et steve
effectivement ce gouvernement que l'on a
vu d'ailleurs arrivée salle des
conférences du sénat
on a pu voir arriver jean castex le
nouveau premier ministre ou encore jean
yves le drian qui est le numéro deux
dans l'ordre protocolaire
juste après jean castex dans ce
gouvernement
notez et bien que l'on a vu aussi
arriver bien jacqueline gourault alors
je vous le disais il va y avoir d'ici
quelques minutes une quinzaine de
questions d'actualité qui vont être
posées à ce nouveau gouvernement jean
castex et jean castex qu'il va devoir
répondre à au moins trois questions car
c'est là à la règle le premier ministre
répond au président de groupe
or patrick kanner président du groupe
socialiste a prévu une question sur la
politique générale de ce gouvernement
est à quelques jours du discours de
politique générale eliane assassi la
présidente du groupe communiste va l
interroger le gouvernement sur la
réforme des retraites est noté également
et bien la question d'hervé marseille et
dont il a donc on a pu entendre à
l'instant sur les relations entre le
gouvernement et le parlement est tout de
suite on va rejoindre steve jourdain
steve car vous êtes avec le sénateur
socialiste jérôme durain oui jérôme
durain bonjour premières impressions sur
ce nouveau ornements avant même le début
de cette séance de questions au
gouvernement
je crois que tout a été dit le nouveau
gouvernement ne vient pas vraiment un
changement radical
il est plus à droite a été notée
on attend les secrétaires d'état voir
s'il ya un peu une recentrage
il ya des bonnes prises pour la presse
les médias et l'opinion avec eric dupond
moretti et roselyne bachelot c'est que
de l'affichage que de la communication
selon vous ça et je sais pas en tout cas
on attend de voir la ligne politique
on a le sentiment quand même que le
président de la république a repris la
main sa a été noté qu'on tape un peu la
fonction de premier ministre
donc on va leur laisser leur chance lors
souhaiter bon courage
et puis on constatera usage sur le fond
quand même parce que l'on sait monsieur
castex et déjà exprimé à ce sujet il y
aura un décalage de cette réforme de
l'assurance-chômage vous saluer ce
décalage écoutez c'était une chose que
nous avions demandé nous même
l'annulation des dispositions qui
avaient été prises la première le
premier volet de cette réforme donc ça
c'est un premier point mais il faut
aller plus loin
on est quand même très inquiet par
ailleurs sur la question des retraites
est ce que la priorité du moment dans le
pays c'est ça alors qu'on va affronter
une crise économique et sociale
particulièrement dure tout le monde le
dit je ne suis pas sûr peut-être un mot
sur le ségur de la santé un peu plus
d'un milliard d'euros a été ajoutée sur
la table par jean castex 7,5 milliards
d'euros au total pour l'hôpital ça
suffit selon vous candice des soignants
incidemment de plus bon voilà donc je
pense que ce ségur il ya des chiffres
qui paraît ce flatteur comme ça de
l'avis d'aidé soignant eux mêmes
le compte n'y est pas enfin il ya un
effort quand même vous reconnaissez un
effort du creusement on peut pas dire
pendant des mois la première ligne nos
soignants ceux qui nous ont sauvés et
par ailleurs ne leur accorder que des
miettes qui a eu un geste qui
semble-t-il n'est pas suffisant pour le
soigneur alors il ya de l'argent mais
aussi un nouveau sujet qui a été menée
sur la table par le gouvernement c'est
la question des effectifs avec de
nouvelles créations d'emplois on parle
de 15 mille créations d'emplois au total
il faut encore davantage de créations
d'emplois pour l'hôpital public ce que
je suis pas un expert des questions de
santé je la commission des lois
on verra comment tout ça s'organise
quels types de postes sont prévues
comment tout ça va se mettre en oeuvre
donc on a les annonces on verra les
résultats prévient on jugera sur pièce
on sera très vigilants merci beaucoup
monsieur du rhin d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci beaucoup et steve notez bien que
d'ailleurs sur ce sujet du secteur de la
santé il va y avoir deux questions qui
vont être posées lors de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
une de la part de martin lévriers
sénateur de la république en marche et
une autre du président de la commission
des affaires sociales le lr alain milon
gageons que ce ne sera pas du tout la
même tonalité est noté que c'est
brigitte bourguignon nouvelle ministre
déléguée chargée de l'autonomie qui va
donc répondre à ces questions
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement où je vous le rappelle est
bien il ya une quinzaine de questions
qui sont prévus pour une séance qui va
durer une heure on attend un certain
nombre de temps forts outre et bien les
réponses de jean castex le nouveau
premier ministre
on attend aussi et bien les changes
entre philippe bas le président l ère de
la commission des lois qui comptent
interroger eric dupond moretti le
nouveau garde des sceaux
le président de la commission des lois
qui va donc interroger l'ancien ténor du
barreau dont la nomination fait couler
beaucoup beaucoup d'encre et que l'on
attend toujours
il n'est pas encore arrivé dans cette
salle des conférences qui jouxte
l'hémicycle où va avoir les sept séances
de questions d'actualité au gouvernement
et tout de suite on va rejoindre steve
jourdain carte il vous êtes avec le
sénateur écologiste rattaché au groupe
rds
ronan dantec oui ronan dantec bonjour
merci d'être avec nous on est en direct
on est en direct
on parle d'un projet de loi qui serait
attendu à la fin de l'été sur la
transition écologique qu'est ce que ce
texte doit contenir selon bain
on sait ce qu'il doit compter contenir
146 propositions venant de la convention
citoyenne donc c'est quand même un
travail considérable ayant moi je suis
un peu sceptique sur le fait que ce
texte arrive dès le mois de septembre
et en plus c'est notre rang réélection
et on a le projet de loi de finances
derrière mais nous on ne va pas attendre
ce projet de loi on est en discussion du
projet de loi de finances rectificatif
dans quelques jours déjà dans ce projet
de loi de finances rectificative nous
mettrons un certain nombre de
propositions qui viennent du travail de
la convention citoyenne et on verra
effectivement si le gouvernement est
prêt déjà les intégrer notamment des
propositions qu'on a déjà fait sur le
financement de l'action climat des
collectivités
ce nouveau gouvernement affiche sa
volonté de soutenir les territoires
ça sera un excellent test pour vérifier
qu'au delà du discours il y à vraiment
volonté de faire ce que vous voulez dire
c'est que les aides de l'état doivent
être conditionnés selon vous à la
conduite en matière d'écologie
ah ben je pense qu'aujourd'hui le budget
de l'état doit être fait de telle
manière de tenir les grands enjeux
environnementaux et notamment les grands
enjeux de réduction des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre c'est pas c'est pas un
dossier périphérie c'est vraiment tout
le budget de l'état qui doit être conçu
de telle manière qu'on tient les grands
objectifs sur l'environnement la
biodiversité tous ces enjeux vous
demander un référendum
écoutez ci s'il ya un consensus
parlementaire un derrière la convention
citoyenne avec le soutien du
gouvernement ya peut-être pas besoin non
plus de référendum si on peut tout
mettre en place tout de suite donc le
référendum c'est si ça bloque
si ça bloque effectivement c'est un
outil pour bien vérifier que la société
française et moi j'en suis convaincu est
en soutien d'une politique
environnementale ambitieuse et que la
société française est actuellement très
pour une grande transformation
je crois que déjà fait lors des
dernières élections la montre et sur un
certain nombre de territoires et toutes
les enquêtes d'opinion le monde mais
surtout la convention citoyenne a été
conçu comme une représentation de la
société française et les propositions de
cette convention citoyenne ont été très
clairs sur le niveau d'ambition
atteindre de la nécessité d'aller
beaucoup plus loin que ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui donc je crois que ce
consensus existe dans la société
française et même un certain nombre de
représentants politiques sont à mon avis
en retard aujourd'hui sur les demandes
de la société peut être dernière
question sur le sujet de la
décentralisation qui est aussi
une certaine manière liés à l'écologie
une conférence un territoire a été
annoncée par emmanuel macron pour cet
été qu'est-ce qu'elle doit contenir
cette conférence sur quoi elle doit
aboutir finalement moi je crois que
cette idée de différenciation est
importante je pense que des régions je
pense à la bretagne
ma région est très demandeuse d'un
certain nombre de compétences mais
d'autres régions aussi donc il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin sur les
compétences et notamment faut aussi
compétences environnementales
aujourd'hui il ya des dispositifs qui
existent sans être trop techniques comme
le plan climat le schéma régional ne
sont pas assez prescriptif ils ne sont
pas ses finances est donc là vraiment on
a déjà des outils mais ils ne sont pas
assez soutenir par l'état je peux même
vous dire qu'avec barbara pompili sera
mon premier sujet de discussion les
prochains jours vous saluer la
nomination de barbara bon pilier à la
tête
moi ce que je vois clair et ce que j'ai
discuté avec les trois qui ont rejoint
tout de suite alexandre poussèrent avec
alain griset plus de temps je ne doute
pas de pouvoir discuter avec elle mais
elle est aussi dans un cadre
gouvernemental dont moi j'attends
effectivement des confirmations au delà
des grands discours sur les priorités
financières et sur les compétences
comble à tous moi je reste dans
l'interrogation à ce stade
merci beaucoup monsieur dantec d'avoir
répondu à mes questions tam
[Musique]
notre assemblée soutiendra les mesures
qui lui paraîtront utile à la relance
économique et pour éviter
vous allez dire atténuer la crise
sociale
deux enjeux majeurs des prochains mois
le sénat est le reflet de nos
territoires
au delà il incarne la nation avec ses
différences sa diversité mais aussi ses
valeurs et son unité sur ses bancs
siègent des élus expérimenté à l'ecoute
des territoires et de nos concitoyens je
forme donc le veut monsieur le premier
ministre que le sénat soit écoutée au
cours des deux années qui viennent
le bicamérisme est une chance pour la
démocratie et l'équilibré de nos
institutions dans une période marquée
par la succession de crises de tension
je vous le dis mes chers collègues la
démocratie représentative est le visage
de la démocratie vivante
pour le respect des règles syndicales
vous est demandé de laisser un siège
vide entre deux sièges occupés ou de
porter le masque si l'affection le nom
vous amène à vous rapprocher
je rappelle que l'hémicycle fait l'objet
d'une désinfection
après chaque séance et que nous
respectons pour le gouvernement sorti
par le devant je parle de sortie de
l'hémicycle et par l'arrière pour les
membres du sénat notre séance et
retransmise sur public sénat et sur
notre site internet
chacun respectera son temps qui à
l'exception du premier ministre qui ici
à des libéralités et de deux minutes
pour l'auteur de la question avec la
possibilité d'une réplique je le dis aux
nouveaux ministres et et et deux minutes
pour les membres du gouvernement la
parole est donc au président hervé
marseille pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres avant tout permettez moi
monsieur le premier ministre de
m'associer aux voeux de bienvenue
exprimée par le président larcher et d'y
ajouter des veaux républicain de
réussite dans l'action que vous avez
amené avec votre gouvernement
en effet nos concitoyens attendent
beaucoup ils attendent des décisions
rapides ils attendent des décisions
fortes pour répondre aux préoccupations
qui les taraude et elles sont nombreuses
notamment concernant l'emploi concernant
la sécurité concernant la dette abyssale
qui maintenant est devenu difficile
concernant toutes sortes de sujets que
vous allez avoir à traiter
très rapidement le président vient de le
dire à l'instant le sénat est
accueillant il a le souci du dialogue
pour peu qu'on veuille bien s'y prêter
car il faut être deux ces dernières
années on ne peut pas dire qu'il y ait
eu une association intensive du
parlement dans la pratique
institutionnelle
j'en veux pour preuve que la réforme des
retraites a été discutée pendant de
longs mois un peu partout sauf ici là le
grand débat après la crise des gilets
jaunes a donné lieu à des débats
importants un peu partout sauf dans les
hémicycles
et puis la politique environnementale
fait l'objet d'une préparation par une
convention citoyenne dont les membres
sont tirés au sort et on n'en parle pas
ici
et puis ce jour après jour on voit des
ordonnances de plus en plus nombreuses
de plus en plus importante qui évite le
parlement alors monsieur le premier
ministre
ma question sera simple le président de
la république s'est pas encore exprimé
il faudra attendre le 14 juillet pour
autant vous pouvez vous nous dire quels
sont vos plus importante priorité celles
que vous comptez a signé à votre
gouvernement et comment entendez vous
associez le sénat ou non à la conduite
de votre politique je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président du sénat mesdames et messieurs
les membres de la haute assemblée je
voudrais vous indiquer au préalable la
vive émotion que je ressens m'exprimant
pour la première fois dans ma fonction
de premier ministre devant vous et en
ayant vous me le permettrais une pensée
toute personnelle pour mon grand-père
qui siégea pendant neuf ans dans cette
assemblée pour y représenter le beau
département du gers sans doute
merci sans doute n'est-il pas
complètement étranger au goût pour le
service de la république qui n'a jamais
cessé de manille mais vous m'avez
monsieur le président
en réalité poser deux questions la
première relative aux priorités de
l'action gouvernementale qu il m'incombe
désormais de conduire avec le
gouvernement qui m'entourent et que je
salue
la deuxième question ici bien sûr
concerne les intentions de ce
gouvernement à l'endroit du parlement et
plus spécifiquement de la haute
assemblée les priorités
en réalité elles sont fixées par le
président de la république
elles seront déclinés devant vous dans
le cadre du discours de politique
générale que je prononcerai la semaine
prochaine mais elles sont également
éclairé
par un contexte nouveau
par bien des aspects inquiétants marquer
vous le savez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs par une crise sanitaire
d'ampleur exceptionnelle qui est vous
savez chers présidents bas que je
connais le sujet une crise sanitaire qui
n'est pas finie et une crise économique
et sociale qui a déjà commencé cela
signifie que le gouvernement de la
république sera tout entier mobilisé
déterminé pour faire face à cette crise
et j'ajoute dans la continuité des
réformes de structure engagées orienter
ses décisions pour que cette crise
vous me passerai la formule nous servent
aussi à moderniser notre pays nous ne
pourrons mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs relever ce défi que si la
france la france est la plus unis
possible et dans ces conditions il
incombe en premier lieu au gouvernement
de la république de rechercher partout
moins bien les conditions de cette unité
et de cette mobilisation
je suis mesdames et messieurs un homme
de dialogue
j'ai par ailleurs la conviction que la
mise en oeuvre des politiques publiques
que le gouvernement conduira quelle
qu'elle soit passera pour être efficace
par les territoires et je suis ici dans
la chambre vous l'avez rappelé monsieur
le président
des territoires je suis dans la chambre
des territoires et je suis moi même vous
le savez un élu issu des territoires
c'est dire monsieur le président si le
rassemblement de ces considérations ne
peut que conduire le gouvernement non
seulement à respecter la représentation
parlementaire mais de surcroît à établir
avec le sénat des relations certes
courtoise républicaine cela va sans dire
mais approfondi dans le but
dans le contexte que nous traversons de
servir nos concitoyens de manière plus
efficace produisent
la parole est à notre collègue martin
lévriers pour le grog la république en
marche
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
madame la ministre chargée de
l'autonomie avant toutes choses
permettez moi de vous adresser mes
félicitations pour votre nomination
ainsi qu'à tous les membres du
gouvernement initialement chargée de
coordonner le déconfinement monsieur le
premier ministre
auxquels j'adresse mes salutations
républicaines et gersoise de coeur
appris sa nomination mission à bras le
corps et s'il est de notre devoir dans
cet hémicycle de rappeler à tous les
français le respect permanent des gestes
barrières
je ne doute pas qu'à cet instant tous
s'accordent à dire qu'il amenait sa
mission avec efficacité le combat contre
le virus n'est pas encore gagné la
preuve en est du déplacement du premier
ministre en guyane où le virus circule
activement
il n'est pas surprenant que dans la
continuité de cette mission menée par le
premier ministre le gouvernement veuille
relevé un premier grand défi conclure
dès cette semaine le ségur de la santé
cette grande concertation souhaitée par
le président de la république lancé le
25 mai dernier par edouard philippe et
olivier ferrand a pour ambition de tirer
collectivement les enseignements de
l'épreuve traversée face à la pandémie
qui nous a frappés faire le lien avec ma
santé 2022 afin de renouveler les
fondations d'un système de santé
toujours plus innovant plus souple au
service des patients
il devra s'appuyer sur les territoires
et prendra en compte l'ensemble des
professionnels par une réelle
revalorisation et par un management
renouvelée
madame la ministre le gouvernement
auquel vous appartenez a annoncé son
désir d'un dialogue fort et clair avec
tous les acteurs concernés et d hier
monsieur le premier ministre a augmenté
de plus d'un milliard l'enveloppent
destiné à la rémunération du personnel
hospitalier
madame la ministre quelle méthode
entendez vous mettre en place pour
favoriser un aménagement équilibré des
territoires et redonner aux acteurs de
la santé qui sont en première ligne et
ont prouvé leur dévouement
le pouvoir d'exercer leur mission en
adéquation avec les enjeux locaux et au
service de tous les français
je vous remercie monsieur le premier
ministre vous réponds oui je sénateurs
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur je me permets de répondre car
évidemment vous touchez un sujet
extrêmement important et dans lequel
vous l'avez rappelé j'ai tenu à
intervenir dès ma prise de fonction je
pense que je n'aurai pas besoin
d'insister devant le sénat sur
l'importance des questions de santé sur
le dévouement absolument remarquable que
tous les professionnels ont démontré et
continue de démontrer dans la crise
sanitaire grave que nous traversons et
vous l'avez dit le gouvernement
mon prédécesseur que je salue tout
particulièrement ont décidé d'engager
cette grande concertation sur le ségur
de la santé je veux préciser au sénat
puisque les mots ont un sens que
parallèlement à la concertation une
négociation a été conduit avec les
partenaires sociaux du secteur notamment
sur les volets salariaux et indemnitaire
de cette profession
le gouvernement souhaite que ces
négociations et c'est très symbolique
par rapport au souci de dialogue que
j'exprimais il y a un instant devant
vous que ces négociations puissent
aboutir sera d'accord majoritaire
le pays en a besoin la santé en a besoin
et j'espère mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que cet accord est à portée de
main vous avez raison de rappeler
que j'ai souhaité que l'effort déjà très
significatif engagé par la nation par
l'état par la nation tout entière en
reconnaissance à ces professions soit à
augmenter pas pour arrêter un accord
majoritaire ou célébrer mon entrée en
fonction
parce que j'ai souhaité introduire dans
cette négociation un deuxième sujet qui
me paraissaient est insuffisamment
couverts et auquel tous les sénateurs
hommes et femmes de terrain sont
sensibles qui est celle de l'emploi dans
les établissements de santé
vous l'avez tous constaté nos
établissements de soins dans certaines
professions manque d'emploi mieux payés
ces professionnels
c'est une question de reconnaissance et
de rattrapable
mais si nous voulons aussi améliorer
l'efficacité du service public de santé
auxquels nos concitoyens sont
particulièrement attachés il faut donner
des moyens pour l'emploi et c'est le
sens de l'intervention que j'ai fait
dernier élément monsieur le président
nous réfléchissons dans le cas de ces
concertations et de ces négociations à
une amélioration de l'organisation de
l'efficience du système qui en a bien
besoin et cela passe je vous le dis par
un accroissement j'allais dire par en
retour du rôle des élus et notamment des
maires dans la gouvernance et le
pilotage du système de santé et du
système hospitalier
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le premier ministre va
parler à notre collègue françoise
laborde pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
vous avez deux minutes merci monsieur le
président au nom de man group le rds je
salue la venue du nouveau premier
ministre et de son gouvernement dans
notre hémicycle
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la relance pour le mot relance mais
bien sûr je serai très contente ce que
madame la ministre délégué chargé de
l'industrie me répondent c'est un
véritable séisme économique qui fait
écho à la crise sanitaire que le monde
entier peine à endiguer aujourd'hui dans
les circonstances d'urgence financière
que nous connaissons
je salue les plans de sauvegarde des
différentes filières industrielles
françaises que votre ministère a su
enclencher très rapidement ils
traduisent un effort national d'un
montant inédit dans l'histoire de notre
économie
destiné à financer des mesures
facilitatrice pour les entreprises 8
milliards d'euros pour la filière
économie automobile 15 milliards pour
l'aéronautique dont 7 pour une aide
directe à air france mon département est
frappé de plein fouet largement
spécialisé dans l'aéronautique avec
toute la chaîne de construction des
avions et le cje où siègent mondiale
d'airbus et aussi avec la filière du
transport aérien
ses nombreuses compagnies et leurs
plateformes régionales la haute-garonne
risque de payer cher le coût social de
cette crise les plans sociaux menace
déjà des dizaines de milliers d'emplois
plus de 5000 suppressions de postes pour
rébus airbus et combien d'autres pour la
supply chain long de choc va impacter
les pme sous-traitantes jusqu'à 30000
emplois seraient touchés
air france pour sa part annonce la
suppression de 7500 postes d'ici 2022
s'ajoute à cette énumération mortifère
les 4600 suppressions d'emplois prévues
par le groupe renault combien de
salariés dans cette succession de
chiffres exorbitants viendront garantir
les effectifs de pôle emploi
si tous les décideurs affirme vouloir
éviter les licenciements secs
je redoute que les promesses non
cash que ceux qui y croient ma question
est simple comment l'état compte t-il
veillée voir sur veiller à ce que les
fonds publics consacrés à la relance de
l'industrie à la sauvegarde la
compétence industrielle soit utilisé
pour effectivement protéger les emplois
en france
je vous remercie pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame agnès pannier rue
nash et ministre délégué chargé de
l'industrie vous avez deux minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice laborde permettez moi d'abord
une note personnelle pour vous mettez et
souhaitez votre anniversaire
mais je vais poursuivre parce que vous
évoquez un sujet qui est délicat et qui
est important et je partage votre
préoccupation pour l'emploi votre
question elle est parfaitement légitime
effectivement nous sommes confrontés à
une crise mondiale et une crise qui a un
impact qui concerne l'ensemble des
chaînes de production boeing a annoncé
il ya quelques temps un plan de
suppression d'emplois de 16 mille
emplois et nous devons nous armer pour
cela je crois que l'état vous l'avez dit
a pris ses responsabilités il a pris ses
responsabilités en mettant en place des
plans de soutien rapides effectif et il
continuera à prendre ses responsabilités
avec un plan de relance qui sera adapté
à la situation et qui visera avant tout
à préserver notre croissance de long
terme a continué à travailler sur la
transition écologique énergétique et
surtout à nous donner les moyens de
préserver notre capital humain et c'est
pour cela que je veux souligner que tous
les plans que nous avons pris plan
automobile plan aéronautique derrière
chaque mesure il y à une attention à
l'emploi lorsque nous quadruple on le
corac les dépenses de recherche et
développement avec l'idée de financer un
avion beaucoup moins carbonée c'est
aussi des emplois d'ingénieurs et de
techniciens que nous préservons lorsque
madame la ministre des armées nous
soutient en décalant décommandés
avançant
c'est directement la chaîne de
production française j'ai cherché qui
est sollicité et qui pourra préserver
des emplois
lorsque nous mettons en place un fonds
d'investissement ou un dispositif
d'activité partielle pour le long terme
c'est également des emplois que nous
accompagnons et nous attendons de la
part des entreprises d'être parfaitement
responsable ce dialogue il se fait dans
le suivi des plans de restructuration je
veux donner un exemple d'air qui a
annoncé mille 300 suppressions d'emplois
ils ont réduit de 800 emplois en entrée
négociations grâce aux mesures de l'état
nous sommes désormais à 500 et nous
allons continuer pour réduire et faire
en sorte qu'ils lui et moi deux départs
contraints
c'est ça n'entre en jeu pour soutenir
l'industrie merci la parole est
maintenant à madame la présidente
eliane assassi pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes
madame la présidente si monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse au
premier ministre à qui j'adresse au nom
de mon groupe la bienvenue au sein de
notre haute assemblée la feuille de
route qui a été fixé par le président de
la république marquent le retour de la
réforme des retraites il n'y aura pas
d'abandon at-il précisé dans la presse
régionale vous-même avait affirmé
vouloir régler ce dossier
à court terme cette réforme a été
suspendu parce qu'elle n'apparaissait
plus prioritaires alors que le président
de la république cherche et la concorde
nationale face à la copie de 10,9 ces
appels à l'unité nationale se fracasse
sur la reprise de ce projet repoussé par
une large majorité de nos concitoyens
vous souffler sur les braises de la
division aig s'appuie sur ce dogme
libéral selon lequel travaillait plus
durant sa vie durant la semaine
c'est la seule voie pour l' équilibre
financier
pourtant les sommes considérables dégagé
pour venir en aide aux entreprises
montrent que les richesses sont là et
peuvent satisfaire l'intérêt général
monsieur le premier ministre la nation
garantit à tous notamment à l'enfant à
la mère et aux vieux travailleurs la
protection de la santé la sécurité
matérielle le repos et le loup et les
loisirs
tout être humain en raison de son âge se
trouve dans l'incapacité de travailler a
le droit d'obtenir de la collectivité
des moyens convenables d'existence le
gaullisme social dont vous vous
revendiquez monsieur le premier ministre
se fonde sur ces mots de l'alinéa
l'alinéa 11 du préambule de la
constitution de 46 toujours en vigueur
aujourd'hui
est-ce conciliables selon vous avec la
déferlante ribéral porté par mais chez
makro allez vous mais sur le premier
ministre oui ou non
renoncer à cette réforme des retraites
dont l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
ne veulent plus entendre parler
aujourd'hui pour vous répondre la parole
et comme monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président madame la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je ne sais pas qui ne veut plus entendre
les de la réforme des retraites mais
refusé de parler des retraites refusé de
parler des retraites
lorsque dès avant la crise mais a
fortiori avec la survenance de cette
dernière
l' équilibre des comptes et donc la
sauvegarde du système actuel se trouve
compromise serait irresponsable il
responsable madame il responsable
je suis comme vous je n'en doute pas
extrêmement attaché au préambule de la
constitution de 1946 et à la conduite
des politiques sociales comme ferment de
notre pacte républicain bien qui peut
dire ici de façon plus structurelle que
notre système de retraite que je connais
bien sûr lequel j'ai travaillé depuis de
nombreuses années est juste il ne l'est
pas il ne l'est pas alors je vais vous
dire madame ce que je compte faire je
vais vous dire ce que je compte faire
premièrement je vais ouvrir le dialogue
toutes les organisations syndicales
viendront discuter avec moi et c'est
heureux que nous ne soyons pas d'accord
avec certains d'entre elles peut-être
nous verrons bien
1 nous rouvrons le dialogue et nous nous
mettons d'accord sur une méthode et un
calendrier
deuxièmement je traiterai j'aborderai la
question des retraites dans un cadre
global la réforme de l'assurance chômage
elle aussi indispensable mais elle aussi
impacté par la crise
jeu et il serait déraisonnable de ne pas
tenir compte de cet élément nouveau la
relance qui sur bien des sujets impact
des considérations qui intéresse les
partenaires sociaux la dépendance moult
fois reporté et que le président de la
république m'a demandé avec mon
gouvernement de conduire
nous allons avoir une approche globale
de ces sujets et s'agissant des
retraites
je proposerai aux partenaires sociaux de
très clairement distingué la réforme que
les spécialistes appellent systémique
la réforme de structure vers un système
plus juste et plus égalitaire pour nos
concitoyens sur lesquels la concertation
va reprendre et ensuite la question de
l' équilibre du système actuel sur
lesquels je demanderai et également aux
partenaires sociaux
madame de me faire leurs propositions
alors même
j'appelle votre attention et celle du
sénat que le système paritaire existence
sur les complémentaires agirc arrco lui
même pour les mêmes raisons confronté à
une menace de déséquilibre les conduira
nécessairement à reprendre le chemin de
la négociation
nous n'avons pas d'autre choix madame la
présidente que de sauvegarder notre
système de protection sociale
même la présidente pour quelques
secondes président très et très
rapidement monsieur le premier ministre
je vous le redis et avec force cette
réforme des retraites est irresponsable
et elle est injuste nous le savons déjà
il y a eu moult rencontres avec les les
syndicats y compris aujourd'hui le medef
se dit opposé à cette réforme
donc nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler mais je dois dire monsieur le
premier ministre que vous êtes là sur un
très mauvais chemin bien
la parole est maintenant aux présidents
patrick kanner pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre au début du précédent
quinquennat j'avais adressé mes voeux de
réussite républicaine à votre
prédécesseur
j'aurais tendance à avoir le même
message pour vous mais entre temps il
faut bien le reconnaître un fossé s'est
creusé entre la politique menée par le
président de la république et les
français ce dernier a déclaré sa volonté
de tracer un nouveau chemin cette
nouvelle orientation les français la
souhaite je vous le confirme ils l'ont
montré en choisissant leur mère et en
sanctionnant lourdement les candidats de
la majorité présidentielle aux élections
municipales
ce nouveau chemin est indispensable pour
affronter la crise économique et sociale
qui est déjà là et qui va s'amplifier et
permettez moi de penser en premier lieu
à la jeunesse de france pour qui il faut
imaginer très vite un plan d'urgence
sociale malheureusement la composition
de votre gouvernement ainsi que vos
premières déclarations me font craindre
nous font craindre que plutôt que d'être
l'incarnation du renouveau vous ne soyez
finalement que l'homme du passif
monsieur prix ministre ce passif est
lourd réforme des retraites tentative de
privatisation da dp loi immigration
assurance-chômage dégradé suppression
lisf crise des gilet jaune je pourrais
continuer mais le temps nous est compté
un bilan qui fragmentent notre pays dans
un climat anxiogène les plus faibles
devraient être mieux protégés
particulièrement en ce moment et vous
devez rassembler les français mais le
premier ministre les protéger les
accompagner face à la crise amorti
certes provisoirement par le
ruissellement de la dette publique mais
que vous faites payer par tous ma
question est simple monsieur le premier
ministre
en clair allez vous changer radicalement
de la politique menée depuis trois ans
allez vous choisir entre les joues
heureux de l'état providence où les
jours désastreux de l'état pénitence
pour vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président monsieur
président caennais repart mais
permettez-moi d'abord de vous présenter
mes félicitations pour le caractère
poétique de vos propos que nous avons
tous apprécié surtout les bons mais je
le cren veut être un peu déconnecté des
réalités
je voulais 10 à la faveur de ma première
intervention le nouveau chemin annoncé
par le président de la république c'est
écrit dans un nouveau contexte nous
devons faire face
je vous le répète président à une crise
qui s'annonce exceptionnel devant nous
pour autant renoncer à un certain nombre
de réformes qui ont été entreprises qui
peuvent se discuter qui devront je le
répète être réorientés dans le cadre de
cette crise et de ce contexte nouveau
sûrement mais me semble-t-il rien ne
serait pire que de faire face à la crise
qui s'annonce en retournant à une forme
d'immobilisme
je l' ai déjà dit et je l'assumé mon
gouvernement est un gouvernement de
combat dans un contexte extrêmement
dégradée j'entends bien puisque vous
avez parlé sur le président de la dette
publique des comptes publics j'apprends
votre vif attachement à ces notions
j'entends bien j'entends bien que nous
tirions les conséquences du passé à
savoir que la lutte contre la crise qui
est déjà là ne soient pas suivis parce
qu'elle en train de nous y sommes
effectivement une dégradation des
comptes sociaux que le président
marseille a déjà évoqué et des comptes
publics en général ne soit pas suivie
dans deux ans dans trois ans par un
matraquage fiscal que d'autres majorités
ont largement déployée pour cela pour
cela nous devons d'abord c'est
l'occasion de le rappeler devant cette
assemblée gérer cette crise
internationale dans un cadre européen
plus que pour la crise de 2008-2010 que
j'ai bien connu il faut que l'europe
s'engage et ne fasse pas porter aux
seuls états et donc in fine et à leurs
contribuables
les mesures réparatrices et
reconstructive que cette crise appelle
il faut aussi que nous puissions isolé
et gérer dans la durée la dette qu'on
appelle des gogos vide que cette crise
un manque ablement va créer mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président je suis ici à la tête d'un
gouvernement à la fois renouvelée avec
des visages nouveaux
incarnant également la continuité très
peu mais ils sont beaux
incarnant la continuité pour
d'arrache-pied réservés les français
tout en continuant de moderniser la
france sur le président kader monsieur
le premier ministre vous vous dites
gaulliste social certes encartés somme
est il aujourd'hui dans un parti
centriste mais j'aurais aimé d'un
gaulliste social entendre des mots
redistribution pouvoir d'achat service
public planification
je pense que ça aurait parlé y compris
une partie de la droite de l'hémicycle
ce n'a pas été le cas et votre réponse
ne me rassure pas sur votre capacité à
gérer l'urgence sanitaire social et
économique qui nous attend dans ce pays
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à notre collègue alain fouché pour
le groupe les indépendants république et
territoires
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre à mon tour au nom du groupe je
voudrais saluer votre arrivée avec notre
gouvernement dans notre assemblée
je m'adresse à monsieur le garde des
sceaux monsieur le garde des sceaux
vous avez déclaré vouloir améliorer la
justice de notre pays
vouloir garder le meilleur échange est
le pire le chantier qui vous attend est
vaste et français ont perdu confiance
dans cette institution elle inspirerait
même de la défiance à près de la moitié
de nos concitoyens selon un très récent
sondage
je n'invente rien qu'il est long et
difficile aujourd'hui d'obtenir justice
face à des procédures complexes et
coûteuses au manque criant de moyens du
main et matérielles nos concitoyens sont
trop nombreux avoir renoncé à faire
valoir leurs droits les français ont
parfois le sentiment persistant que
l'institution judiciaire de notre pays
est forte avec les faibles et faible
avec les forts l'arbitraire la plus
grande menace qui pèse sur la justice et
ce n'est pas récent le meilleur rempart
contre cela réside dans le respect des
formes et des procédures
la loi date est la même pour tous soit
qu'elle protège soit qu'elle punisse
vous l'avez dit monsieur le garde des
sceaux la justice de son nid dans la rue
et sous les réseaux sociaux ni dans les
médias
il s'agit d'une des missions
essentielles de l'état c'est aussi l'une
des des institutions les plus
nécessaires à notre démocratie
elle doit être dotée de moyens à la
hauteur de sa mission
les français ont besoin d'une justice
efficace rapide et accessible
monsieur le ministre avec l'expérience
qui est la vôtre vous avez déclaré qu'il
fallait revoir l'institution judiciaire
de a à z
pouvez vous nous dire quelles sont les
mesures prioritaires que vous comptez
prendre pour vous répondre
la parole est au garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice monsieur dupont
moretti vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
le sénateur quelques secondes brève dans
ces courtes minutes
2 je crois pour tenir d'abord ma ma
fierté mon émotion la confiance du
président de la république monsieur le
premier ministre
faut que je mesure ici à cet instant le
bilité de la tâche qui est la mienne et
je voudrais vous dire que la
connaissance que j'ai de la justice est
une connaissance empirique
hier j'ai dit charnel laisse moi laissez
moi s'il vous plaît à prendre mon
administration se faire j'aurais
naturellement besoin de tous les
parlementaires de la majorité et je ne
suis pas un politique comme de
l'opposition
il est possible voyez vous de faire
évoluer la procédure pénale de a à z ou
de ac mais peu importe de a à z en
quelques mois c'est compliqué mais tout
de même
sachez que lors de la commission d'
enquête parlementaire d'outreau
des parlementaires de toutes
sensibilités ont réussi parce que la
justice nous l'avons au coeur ont réussi
à transcender tous les clivages et ont
proposé 80 de modification de notre
procédure pénale
je m'appuierai d'ailleurs sur ce travail
ce que je veux par exemple c'est une
justice de proximité
bien sûr il ya le budget mais il y a
aussi les hommes l'humanité ça ne coûte
rien le doute
non mais les hommes au sens ne me prenez
pas sur ce terrain les hommes au sens
chez les hommes et les femmes les femmes
ou les hommes
sané sané le signe de rien madame pardon
alors je voudrais terminer mon propos
il ya par exemple des choses toutes
simples remettre au coeur de la justice
la présomption d'innocence éviter des
enquêtes préliminaires qui ne sont plus
préliminaire et qui s'éternise sans
aucun contradictoires
quelque chose de très simples voyous et
ça ça n'est pas une question budgétaire
les victimes qui parfois ne sont même
pas reçu par le juge d'instruction ça
c'est très simple à mettre en oeuvre
j'ai d'ailleurs demandé aux procureurs
généraux qu'ils viennent me voir pour
qu'on parle de cela j'ai lu également
qu'un syndicat de magistrats du siège
disait alors déjà on va donner des
ordres
alors si nous ne faisons pas avec les
procureurs généraux nous le ferons avec
vous c'est tout simple de demander à une
victime devenir une justice plus proche
plus humaine
je suis allé hier en détention je le
garde des sceaux vous rap un tout petit
peu achevée vous est pris par le temps
vous me les fichiers de aller c'est
parce que c'est la première fois à les
[Applaudissements]
accorder mois le bénéfice de
l'inexpérience au cou monsieur couchez
vous avez quelques secondes
non
appuyez sur le bouton et moi monsieur le
président le ministre a donné un certain
nombre d'éléments qui n'est pas pareil
que d'être clair et intéressant tu
démarres fait partie de la profession
d'avocat je connais les choses donc il
ya des choses qui sont intéressantes
bientôt proposée qui ne fonctionne pas
aujourd'hui voilà alors la parole et au
président philippe bas pour le groupe
l'est républicain
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président est d'abord
au nom de mon groupe je veux à mon tour
souhaité la bienvenue au sénat au
nouveau gouvernement
ma question est aussi pour le garde des
sceaux monsieur le ministre je vais
changer ma question parce que monsieur
foucher vient de vous interroger et je
ne suis pas satisfait de votre réponse
vous donnez une image incontestablement
forte de la justice ce faisant vous
créez une énorme attente
vous avez dressé hier un constat un
constat sans doute sévère mais un
constat que je crois lucide ce constat
nous l'avons fait nous aussi dans notre
rapport de 2010 7 5 ans pour sauver la
justice les justiciables qui piétine aux
portes des tribunaux des magistrats et
des greffés privé du moyen de faire
correctement leur travail des avocats
qui se comptent par milliers en
situation de précarité une
administration pénitentiaire à bout de
souffle des détenus qui sortent de
prison sans être préparé à la
réinsertion et qui vont rejoindre les
gros contingent de récidivistes et face
à cela monsieur le ministre vous n'avez
pas pu accepter cette fonction sans
avoir reçu de force d'assurance du
premier ministre et du président de la
république car le redressement de la
justice est à l'ordre du jour et je
voudrais vraiment savoir plus
précisément que dans votre réponse à
monsieur foucher ce que vous entendez
faire pour faire face à ce défi
essentiel du service public de la
justice
la parole est à monsieur le le garde des
sceaux monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président vous me demandez
donc à moins ce que m'a dit monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur premier
ministre m'a dit que la loi de
programmation serait quant à vos travaux
vous allez être satisfait je l'espère
ils sont d'ores et déjà sur mon bureau
je vous fais la confession que je n'ai
pas encore eu le temps de tout lire
mais je le ferai vous serez bien
évidemment conviés nous parlerons
ensemble de cela j'envisage très
prochainement de recevoir tous les
présidents eux deux groupes jeudi tous
les présidents de groupe g comment vous
le dire autrement peu besoin de vous
j'ai besoin de vos conseils
j'ai besoin de votre contradictoires et
nous avons besoin ensemble de faire
évoluer la justice de notre pays
nous sommes le pays dans le rang des
pays les plus condamnés nous occupons le
triste douzième rang sur 47 pays
la plupart des condamnations étant
intervenu pour un procès qui n'est pas
un procès équitable
et cela ce n'est pas une question de
budget non répondent la parole et au
président pas pour vous répondre
pour vous répliqué au président philippe
bas
monsieur le ministre vous allez nous
recevoir et nous nous allons vous
auditionné après la déclaration de
politique générale du premier ministre
nous sommes pressés de vous entendre
nous voulons rentrer dans les détails
vous avez mis la barre haut et même
peut-être très haut c'est la bonne
altitude et maintenant à vous de la
franchir
merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
la parole est au président alain milon
pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur présidente ma question
s'adresse plus particulièrement monsieur
le premier ministre nous savons que le
coc u19 monsieur pomy ce n'est pas un
virus saisonnier stoppée par la hausse
des températures la période estivale ne
doit donc pas entraîner un relâchement
dans la mise en place des actions de
prévention
preuve que le virus est toujours là
plusieurs de nos voisins européens en
particulier l'italie l'espagne le
portugal est encore l'allemagne ont
recours à nouveau à deir confinement
locaux 2 5 millions de personnes se
trouvent actuellement recombiner
monsieur prémunissent ce matin vous avez
déclaré qu'il faut se préparer à une
éventuelle deuxième vague
nous savons que la circulation du virus
en cette période sera démultipliée par
les mouvements saisonniers de population
quelles actions concrètes
allez vous donc mettre en place pour
éviter une nouvelle flambée d'épidémie
dans notre pays
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
oui monsieur le président ce président
milon jeu reprend la parole puisque
c'est un sujet extrêmement important qui
relève de la crise dans l'ensemble de
notre pays
vous avez dit monsieur paisible dans
milon que j'avais déclaré ce matin c'est
exact que nous devions anticiper une
deuxième vague
je me permets de rappeler au sénat en
particulier à la commission des lois et
à son président que c'est déjà très
exactement ce que j'avais déclaré devant
elle à la faveur d'une audition la
première d'ailleurs dont j'avais fait
l'objet lorsqu'edouard philippe m'avait
chargé de préparer le déconfinement du
pays
j'avais d'ailleurs été surpris à
l'époque que les principales réactions
autour de cette audition qui avait été
longue s'était focalisé
le président bah ça se souviendra sans
doute sur cette phrase en va sitôt qu'on
prépare le déconfinement var confiné bas
en réalité il est de leur devoir de
l'état et tous les pays qui nous
entourent le fond de préparer
d'anticiper l'évolution de cette
épidémie mais aussi monsieur président
de tirer tous les enseignements des
phases antérieures
j'observe avez-vous tout avec vous tous
cas ce jour à ce jour y compris par
rapport à des pays voisins que vous
venez de citer la circulation virale
dans notre pays reste plus limité mais
rien ne dit rien lui rien ne permet
d'affirmer que cela ne va pas changer
je me permet d'indiquer au sénat vous le
savez je m'adresse en particulier aux
élus ultramarins qui lie à dans la
république des zones encore extrêmement
frappé je pense en particulier à la
guyane où j'ai décidé de me rendre dès
dimanche
les retours d'expérience que nous avons
nous conduisent d'abord à faire des
actions beaucoup plus ciblées de
prévention par des tests avant même que
des signes cliniques ne nous conduise
c'est déjà la doctrine en vigueur à les
pratiquer deuxièmement je pense que nous
avons acquis dans le traitement de ce
qu'on appelle les clusters un savoir
faire qui nous permet d'éviter une
diffusion excessive
troisièmement il nous faut tout faire
tout faire pour éviter si une nouvelle
vague venait à frapper notre pays pour
éviter un record finement généralisée
comme nous l'avions fait initialement
compte tenu des circonstances
car sinon notre pays notre économie
notre vie sociale en serait très
profondément impactés c'est donc et
c'est le sens de mon intervention
monsieur le président un sujet vous le
comprendrez
compte tenu de ses impacts pour la santé
de nos concitoyens et pour la survie de
notre économie que j'entends suivre très
directement à mon niveau sur le
président bis dont le premier ministre
de cette réponse qui est quand même une
réponse extrêmement général nous avons
actuellement l'expérience des aéroports
nous savons très bien que nos
concitoyens qui partent à l'étranger
sont eux tester les français qui partent
à l'étranger sont venus tester mais nous
savons aussi que ce qui vient de
l'étranger en particulier de pays
infectés par le cos vide ne sont pas
testés dans nos aéroports actuellement
et c'est là que se trouve le danger
il faut à tout prix que nous ayons cette
ce que vous venez de dire
t
tu es isolé mais testé en particulier
dans les aéroports et haut niveau nos
frontières vous savez je viens d'une
région qui est pas loin de la vôtre la
provence vous savez que des ouvriers
espagnols sont venus travailler chez
nous en provence il était positif
ils n'ont pas été testés à la frontière
ils ont été testés hamas dans le petit
village que vous connaissez vous
connaissez le vaucluse à mazan ou en
avons eu 20/20 ouvriers espagnols qui
étaient testés positifs et qui se sont
promenés dans l'ensemble du vaucluse à
ce moment là donc il est extrêmement
urgent qu au niveau de nos frontières et
au niveau des aéroports
les étrangers qui viennent de pays ce
pas tester eux aussi merci monsieur le
président la parole est à notre collègue
claude raynal pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain c'est le président merci
monsieur le premier ministre
madame la ministre notre pays est dans
une situation d'urgence nous l'avons dit
l'urgence sanitaire toujours urgence
économique et social surtout tant les
dégradations des chiffres de la
croissance comme de l'emploi sont
rapides et brutales mais alors que toute
notre attention devrait d'évidence
focaliser sur les conséquences
économiques et sociales de cette
pandémie
le propos du président de la république
plus le vôtre monsieur le premier
ministre
place la relance de la réforme des
retraites au premier rang des urgences
gouvernementale notre pays
vous l'avez dit a besoin de se
rassembler pour faire face de se
rassembler
pas de se fracturer or la réforme des
retraites est tout sauf un projet
fédérateur
elle a inquiété puis suscité une forte
opposition des français
le chiffon rouge de l'âge pivot tout
comme la cicatrice du 49-3 interrompant
le processus démocratique à l'assemblée
nationale reste vivace dans nos esprits
cette idée de rouvrir le débat en début
d'été a été également provoqué une forte
opposition des syndicats ouvriers comme
patronaux cette appréciation commune est
d'ailleurs assez rare pour être souligné
monsieur le premier ministre vous
prêchez le dialogue écoute la recherche
du compromis je vous cite comment
pouvez-vous sur cette base annoncé la
reprise des travaux sans aucune
concertation préalable et sans avoir
négocié avec les partenaires
quelqu un jeune d'à social que ce soit
cela augure mal de
suite en faisant cela vous remobiliser à
contre temps les forces vives de notre
pays contre un projet pour une large
part un compris là où vous auriez dû les
mobiliser pour relancer notre économie
et anticiper les difficultés sociales à
venir
il en est de même de l'assurance chômage
pour cause de pandémie
vous avez retardé l'entrée en
application c'est assez dire que vous en
mesurer les effets dévastateurs pour les
plus précaires comme pour les cadres
d'ailleurs le contexte a changé du tout
au tout il est impératif d'abroger ce
texte de se remettre autour de la table
monsieur le premier ministre madame la
ministre ma question est simple la crise
de 2008 comme celle d'aujourd'hui
montrent les qualités et la pertinence
de notre modèle social
qu'attendez vous pour le renforcer
plutôt que de chercher à l'affaiblir
pour vous pour vous répondre la parole
et madame elisabeth bornes ministre avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur mais je pense que la crise
sanitaire que l'on traverse
et la crise sociale économique et social
qui menace est effectivement inédite et
elle nous amène à rouvrir le dialogue
sur les nombreux sujets que vous avez
mentionné mais d'autres comme monsieur
le premier ministre l'a évoqué que ce
soit le plan de relance que ce soit la
dépendance que ce soit ces sujets de
l'assurance chômage ou de la réforme des
retraites
c'est avant tout une volonté de dialogue
de faire vivre la démocratie sociale
avec tous les acteurs avec tous les
partenaires sociaux qui ont été exprimés
à la fois par le président de la
république et par le premier ministre
cette crise elle nous confronte à de
nouveaux problèmes mais elle n'efface
pas les difficultés qui préexistait que
ce soit sur la justice de notre système
de retraite
que ce soit sur l'efficacité de
l'indemnisation de l'assurance chômage
et donc c'est vraiment dans le dialogue
avec l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
avec l'ensemble des parlementaires qu'on
doit ensemble trouver le chemin pour
protéger nos concitoyens face à la crise
qui s'annonce et pour bâtir le nouveau
modèle de protection sociale à la
hauteur des enjeux du 21e siècle et
c'est donc bien le sens les
concertations qui vont être engagées dès
demain par le premier ministre pour
rencontrer l'ensemble des partenaires
sociaux et pour ab élaborer une feuille
de route pour prendre en compte
l'ensemble de ces sujets et répondre aux
attentes de nos concitoyens jour merci
merci la parole est notre collègue
jacqueline eustache brinio pour le
groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres
chers collègues les élections
municipales ont montré ce que nous
rendions nous redoutions tous une
poussée de l'entrisme communautariste
dans les listes municipales dans le val
d'oise cousin ville est revenu un
candidat dont le profil interroge même
les services de renseignement à
garges-lès-gonesse la ville a failli
tomber entre les mains d'une fondateur
du ccf à strasbourg le hidjab pire
symbole de l'infériorisation de
l'enfermement de la négation du corps de
la femme a fait son entrée au conseil
municipal
dans ces villes comme dans d'autres
l'islam politique trace son chemin
face à un manque cruel de courage pour y
faire obstacle
et préserver notre unité et les valeurs
de la république
le constat de ces élections municipales
et celui du début malheureusement d'un
morcellement inquiétant que personne ne
peut nier
il ya quelques mois le président la
république avait indiqué vouloir
combattre le séparatisme islamiste à ce
jour nous n'avons toujours ni ligne
directrice ni cap clair vous lutter
efficacement contre ces dérives qui mène
à la fracture de notre pays à ce sujet
comme sur tant d'autres il vous
appartient monsieur ministre de ne pas
être spectateur jeu revenir monsieur le
ministre sur certains de vos propos à ce
sujet et qui m'interroge en effet il y a
quelques années
aviez parlé de laïcité punitive or la
laïcité ne doit jamais être agréé
adjectiv et dit faire l'objet d'un
commandement par ailleurs vous aviez
suggéré l'idée d'un nouveau concordat
avec l'islam qui remettrait gravement en
cause les principes mêmes de la loi de
1905 et qui dénaturerait la conception
largement partagé par les français de la
laïcité
monsieur le ministre s'engager pour la
france c'est accepter de se faire
détester par une minorité gesticulante
au profit d'une majorité qui ne
demandent qu'une chose vivre en paix et
en harmonie dans cette france
intégratrice et tolérante
quel chemin monsieur le ministre allez
vous prendre quelle réponse allez vous
apporter à cet islam politique qui tenta
assignée à résidence et à exclure de la
république
une partie de nos concitoyens au profit
d'une âme religieuse pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur gérald darmanin savez la parole
du ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice
le président de la république et le
premier ministre m'ont fait confiance
avec marlène schiappa qui travaille
auprès de moi pour continuer à rétablir
la sécurité des français pour
accompagner bien sûr le travail des
services publics intermédiaire du corps
préfectoral pour rendre respect écoute à
nos forces de l'ordre mais également
bien sûr pour lutter contre ce que le
président de la république dans son
discours a qualifié de séparatisme et
oui l'islam politique est un ennemi
mortel pour la république
oui il faut combattre toute forme de
communautarisme mais il me semble madame
que le miz intérieure est également le
ministre des cultes et qu'en france est
citée ne veut pas dire la négation de
cette liberté des cultes et il me semble
que vous propose sont un petit peu
caricatural tout en étant très ferme
caricaturaux je veux que vous suivez
[Musique]
madame mon grand-père prier allah et
porter l'uniforme de la république et il
m'a semblé que bien des tirailleurs
algériens et bien des supplétifs ont par
ailleurs tout en priant pour leur
religion défendu les valeurs de la
république
alors oui oui à la liberté de culte non
à la caricature non à l'islamisme
politique où il ya des français quelle
que soit leur couleur de peau quelle que
soit leur religion
madame si nous pouvions discuter de ce
qui fait nation c'est-à-dire la
marseillaise la culture la langue notre
drapeau est pas tombé sur des
caricatures
vous avez eu la gentillesse de me citer
vous avez la gentillesse de me citer
vous verrez madame que je suis très fier
de l'assimilation française mon premier
prénom à gérald mon deuxième prénom et
moussa et face au président de la
république et grâce à ceux qui m'ont
accompagné je suis très fier d'être mise
la république percer la parole et d'un
autre collègue nathalie goulet pour le
groupe de l'union centriste lever la
parole oui monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
garde des sceaux ma question s'adresse à
vous d'abord bienvenue dans cette dans
cet hémicycle au sénat nous avons
toujours été très attentif au sort des
prisonniers notamment des tenues pour
cause de terrorisme mais aussi des
détenus radicaliser si nos décomptes
sont exacts plus de 150 d'entre eux
sortiront de détention en 2022
auxquels s'ajoutent les 300 qui sont
sortis jusqu'à maintenant ils sont
d'ailleurs nombreux à voir prêter
allégeance à l'état islamique cette
organisation qui revendique
l'application par ses membres de la
taqiyya c'est-à-dire de l'art de la
dissimulation et de la fosse repentance
statistiquement un certain nombre
d'entre eux tout juste sorti de prison
auront la détermination à nouveau de
frapper notre pays et nos concitoyens ce
ministre madame b loubet a toujours
apporté sur ces questions des réponses
rassurantes sur le suivi la sortie des
détenus radicaliser
des propos qui malheureusement sont
restés un peu flous et surtout qu'ils
ont manqué de moyens alors j'ai bien
entendu que monsieur le premier ministre
a annoncé des moyens pour la justice ce
matin mais il va falloir faire avec ses
moyens et vous avez vu le nombre de
questions qui vous sont posées sur
l'organisation de la justice donc avec
la détermination qui vous caractérise
quelles mesures comptez prendre
comptez-vous prendre monsieur le
ministre pour faire face à cette
situation notamment pour le suivi au des
détenus radicaliser à la fois en prison
et surtout au moment de leur sortie sur
le garde des sceaux pour répondre à
madame boulet il avait la parole
monsieur le monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice dans quelques jours
savez sans doute j'aurai l'honneur de
revenir devant vous dans une expression
qui sera je l'espère un peu plus longue
pour vous faire connaître la position du
gouvernement sur la proposition de loi
relative aux mesures de sûreté des
sortants de prison radicaliser mon
ministère
c'est le ministère de la liberté et des
libertés
mais je suis évidemment préoccupés bien
sûr par la sécurité des français
nous examinerons ce texte je vous dirai
ce que j'en pense
l' équilibre entre la liberté et la
sûreté parfois un équilibre précaire
difficile à trouver sur tout et
particulièrement dans une grande
démocratie ce qui est distingue la
barbarie de la civilisation c'est la
règle de droit et c'est son application
sur les chiffres pardon je veux y
revenir un tout petit instant voilà ceux
qui m'ont été communiquées
soixante détenus ou condamnés pour
terrorisme 550 de droit commun suivi au
titre de la radicalisation 74 d'entre
eux ont bénéficié des récentes mesures
de libération anticipée
il leur restait deux mois de prison un
peu moins de deux mois de prison avec 7
ces mesures post pénales sont au coeur
au coeur de mes préoccupations
j'aurais évidemment là encore besoin de
vous et nous aurons une concertation une
discussion dans la contradiction et l'
écoute mutuelle et réciproque mais
sachez que mon ministère est très proche
de toutes ces questions là bien sûr
madame madame boulet oui mais ses
ministres etc ou des chevaux je vous
remercie de votre réponse est vrai que
dans quelques jours nous aurons ce texte
mais voyez vous si ce texte a été déposé
c'est parce que précisément il y avait
des trous dans le dispositif depuis que
les gens sortent ne sont pas suivies 12
ans sans jamais d'application du
mécanisme de rétention de sûreté et de
surveillance de sécurité le suivi socio
judiciaire
à peine appliquée donc nous avons besoin
évidemment de ces mesures fortes nous
avons aussi besoin de mesures fortes
dans les prisons et je vais j'ai utilisé
les trois secondes qui me reste pour
vous inviter monsieur le ministre à
venir visiter la prison de
condé-sur-sarthe alençon qui est la
prison de mon département et vous verrez
le personnel pénitentiaire qui est en
charge des détenus les plus dangereux
je crois qu'ils seront contents de vous
entendre merci la parole est à notre
collègue laurent duplomb pour le groupe
l'est républicain
monsieur le président madame la ministre
l'écologie est un sujet qui est dans
tous les discours bien pensant
pourtant les décisions prises sur
l'autel sacrificielle de la décroissance
devrait nous questionner notre pays va
connaître la pire crise depuis 1929
dixit le ministre le maire et vous
prenez des décisions qui coûte cher et
dont l'impact sur la planète sera pire
deux exemples parmi tant d'autres
fessenheim
avec l'arrêt des deux réacteurs
l'énergie qu'ils auraient produite avec
des rejets de co2 limités saura achetées
en allemagne ce qui coûte plus chère
avec un bilan carbone liées à une
production au charbon qui dégagera des
millions de tonnes de co2
supplémentaires
cherchez l'erreur deuxième exemple la
case ya ou quinine de cayenne additifs
très utilisé dans les boissons gazeuses
et dans les cosmétiques est autorisé
pour l'agriculture en allemagne en
pologne en suisse en autriche est
interdite en france
elle pourrait être utilisée pour tuer
les larves doblo campent dans la pomme
elle elle ne l'est pas et nos
agriculteurs se retrouvent
elle est même interdite en france et nos
agriculteurs et surtout en bio sont
remis dans une impasse technique et les
français consommeront encore des
produits importés contenant des
substances interdites chez nous alors je
vous le demande
madame la ministre avez vous conscience
des conséquences néfastes et paradoxal
de cette écologie punitive pensez vous y
remédier
pour vous répondre la parole de pia
madame la ministre de la transition
écologique
madame pompidou vous avez la parole
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur merci pour votre
question qui me permet d'abord de
remercier monsieur le président la
république monsieur le premier ministre
pour me faire confiance justement pour
endosser ce gros enjeux de l'écologie
ces gros enjeux de l'écologie je crois
qu'il faut les prendre différemment de
ce que de la manière dont vous les
présenter monsieur le sénateur
l'écologie en soi n'est pas punitive au
contraire l'écologie c'est l'espoir et
c'est la possibilité de vivre demain
dans un monde meilleur pour nous pour
nos enfants mais aussi pour notre
économie pour nos emplois mais
l'écologie ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'il faut anticiper il
faut essayer de se projeter un peu dans
l'avenir de prendre toujours un temps
d'avancé pour éviter de se retrouver
dans des difficultés que nous aurons dès
que nous aurons du mal à gérer
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui avec
la crise que nous vivons dont nous avons
vu et les scientifiques nous le dise
qu'elle a des origines notamment
environnementales à cause de la perte de
la biodiversité
donc on peut continuer à se fermer les
yeux ou on peut regarder la réalité en
face
pour les agriculteurs je ne connais pas
un agriculteur monsieur le sénateur pas
un qui est heureux de diffuser des
produits phytosanitaires sur ses terres
pains tout ce qu'ils souhaitent c'est
avoir des bons produits et c'est pour
voir c'est pouvoir vivre décemment de
leur travail et d'être reconnus et qu'on
arrête les oppositions stériles entre
les uns et des autres les agriculteurs
c'est le coeur des territoires et sur
les territoires dont vous êtes les
représentants messieurs les sénateurs
on aura besoin et madame et mesdames les
sénatrices vous avez raison pardon chers
collègues
vous avez parfaitement raison on va
avoir besoin de transcrire dans les
faits cette anticipation de prévoir
l'avenir de prévoir des emplois de
demain de prévoir effectivement dans la
transition énergétique de rééquilibrer
notre mixte pour ne pas être dépendant
d'une énergie par rapport à une autre
est de pouvoir recréer des emplois parce
que les énergies notamment renouvelable
mais pas seulement sont très génératrice
d'emplois sur les territoires de la même
manière la rénovation thermique des
logements par exemple ça aussi c'est des
emplois sur les territoires non
délocalisables qui vont faire du bien à
notre environnement coq les exemples
comme ça nous en avons des tonnes et je
suis là pour les mettre en oeuvre et
vous pouvez compter sur moi merci
monsieur du plomb
comme votre collègue madame la ministre
nicolas hulot vous prenez être pour le
juste échange et contre le libre échange
alors que vous vous êtes abstenu lors du
vote sur le ceta on peut légitimement se
dire que votre revendication relève
plutôt de la posture politique que de
convictions profondes
d'ici à ce que vous fassiez comme
michael j'aime berger écologiste de la
première heure qui affirme je cite au
nom des écologistes je tiens à m'excuser
pour avoir répandu l'apport climatique
titre de trop dans lequel il dénonce la
déclaration apocalyptique sur le climat
qui est scientifiquement erronées et
politiquement contre-productive et il
n'y avait pas pour que vous y arriviez
la parole est notre collègue nathalie
delattre pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre julien de
normandie je me fais la porte parole des
territoires viticoles pour vous
souhaiter la bienvenue dans cette noble
fonction de ministre de l'agriculture
présidente de l'association nationale
des élus de la vigne et du vin
ma question vous en doutez concerne sept
secteur vitivinicole en gironde comme
dans bien d'autres d'être terroir pardon
la viticulture est le premier employeur
du département à l'échelle nationale
elle génère plus de cinq cent mille
emplois
mais cette filière crucial à l'économie
française est aujourd'hui en voie de
disparition
le changement climatique la situation
dégradée des marchés internationaux
la taxe trump le confinement qu'ovide en
précipiter nos exploitations dans une
grande détresse leur apporter votre
appui relève désormais de l'urgence
l'état a débloqué des milliards pour
aider certaines filières il faut en
salué le principe c'était un besoin
impérieux
mais la viticulture ne mérite tels que
des miettes l'enveloppent débloqués par
le gouvernement ne suffit même pas à
financer la seule distillation de crise
monsieur le ministre allez vous apporter
un soutien à la viticulture à la hauteur
ce qu'elle représente pour la france
merci pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
julien de normandie vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice nathalie delattre
d'abord je voudrais saluer votre
engagement sur votre territoire nous
nous connaissons depuis longtemps en
tant que personnes qui travaillent au
jour le jour sur ces beaux sujets mais
également en tant que présidente de
l'association des élus du vin de manière
très précise la réponse sera oui oui je
m'engagerai pleinement au bénéfice de
cette filière au bénéfice de nos
territoires au bénéfice de tous les pans
de cette agriculture qui sont autant
d'éléments de notre identité de notre
identité au jour le jour mais de notre
identité également pour énormément de
ces territoires que nous chérissons
alors les défis sont immenses et vous le
savez mieux que quiconque il ya d'abord
ces taxes au niveau international vous
avez en tête que le gouvernement a fait
je salue ce que didier guillaume a pu
faire vis-à-vis des etats-unis sur les
aides export sur le doublement des des
financements de france business ou autre
il y a deuxième élément la question des
volumes liée à la distillerie et j'ai en
tête le sujet je ne rentrerai pas dans
le détail mais nous le partageons avec
beaucoup ici j'ai en tête le sujet
précis du volume retirer sur le marché
sur lequel il y à une question de savoir
s'il faut aller plus loin et je m'engage
à ouvrir ce dossier pour qu'on puisse
trouver les solutions
troisième élément pour ne pas être trop
long mais je vois qu'il n'ya pas de
temps donc j'imagine
monsieur le président que ce sujet du
vin et passionne tellement qu'il n'ya
pas de temps limité dans ce qu'il s'agit
de l'évoquer le troisième le troisième
sujet
c'est la question dans le gie comme le
titrage du vol c'est à la sortie de
l'alambic
donc il faut conclure monsieur lui dis
merci monsieur le président le troisième
sujet sera sur l'accompagnement
spécifique nous en reparlerons dans le
cadre du plfr 3 et enfin ayant en tête
que suite à beaucoup d'action faite par
la france auprès du parlement et de la
commission
il y a eu des adaptations
les règles de marché qui pas plus tard
qu'hier ont enfin été adoptée par la
commission et c'était très bien assis je
sais que vous aviez longuement poussé
pour ce faire et je vous en remercie
merci beaucoup madame nathalie delattre
vous avez vraiment 45 secondes merci
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
j'entends bien votre réponse mais les
mots ne suffiront pas je me permets de
vous chauffez trois mesures fortes que
vous pourriez prendre en urgence un
fonds de compensation français de 300
millions d'euros pour dédommager nos
exploitations viticoles face à la taxe
trump l'amendement de l'envelope dédié à
la distillation de crise oui parlons-en
mais il faut surtout le faire et enfin
de véritables énorme exonérations de
charges
le plfr 3 prévoit un dispositif global
tous secteurs confondus mais son
application
de fait exclus plus de 80 % des
exploitations vitivinicole les
entreprises viticoles non pas bénéficier
du chômage partiel puisque le travail
agricole a continué dans nos vignes
pendant le confinement mais comment
payer les charges
lorsqu'en regard vous n'avez quasi
aucune recette
votre prédécesseur nous avait promis un
dispositif spécifique où est il il est
indispensable cycliste d'ouvrir les
vannes à l'agriculture sinon dans
quelques mois
nos paysages viticoles n'offriront plus
que des friches désolante et des emplois
détruits
merci la parole dès maintenant notre
collègue gibert gilbert luc devinaz pour
le groupe socialiste et républicain
vous avez la parole merci merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre
le constat du haut conseil pour le
climat est clair et sans appel
manque de suivi des politiques annoncées
manque de fermeté dans le pilotage
dit autrement la france au lieu de
rattraper les retards du passé en
accumulent de nouveau la crise que nous
vivons illustre la vigne vulnérabilité
de nos sociétés au choc choc sanitaire
aujourd'hui chocs climatiques demain
nous sommes presque tous d'accord sur le
constat
c'est le moment ou jamais de concilier
relance de l'activité et engagement fort
dans la lutte contre le changement
climatique
surtout quand l'état investi autant
d'argent dans l'économie comme on dit il
n'ya pas d'amour mais seulement des
preuves d'amour où sont les preuves
d'une relance industrielle plus durable
le président de la république a annoncé
vouloir localiser une partie de
l'industrie l'humidex du médicament que
voit-on dans le rhône 128 licence
salariés de l'entreprise aux médicaments
famars vont être licenciées fin juillet
une nouvelle usine sanofi sur la
métropole de lyon certes 3 une semaine
après une annonce par sanofi d'un plan
de licenciement de mille personnes en
france alors qu'en sera-t-il des belles
déclarations pour une relance plus verte
pour l'instant je ne vois rien dans le
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif pour autant ce ne sont pas
les actions qui manquent notamment dans
un secteur avec des entreprises non
délocalisables au service de la
médiation des logements un secteur qui
aidera plus de 5 millions de personnes
qui souffrent de précarité énergétique
cinq millions de personnes qui payent
cher leur chauffage qui ont trop froid
l'hiver trop chaud l'été aux problèmes
de santé madame la ministre
combien d'argent allez-vous débloqués
pour aider à la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments
pour vous répondre à la parole qu'à
madame emmanuelle bach dont les ministre
délégué chargé du logement devait la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur merci pour cette
question qui ne me permet d'affirmer mon
engagement complet en tant que ministre
du logement sur la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments engagement
complet dans la continuité de
l'engagement de julien de normandie qui
a toujours dit qu'il était autant le
ministre de la rénovation que de la
construction engagement complet à
l'intérieur du grand ministère de la
transition écologique puisque le
logement rejoint ce grand ministère ce
qui nous permettra sous l'autorité du
premier ministre et du président de la
république de gagner encore en cohérence
en efficacité en capacité à agir sur ce
sujet vous avez raison la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments et clé en
france pour le climat pour la planète
pour le pouvoir d'achat et pour notre
activité économique est les clés parce
que ça sera un élément important du plan
de relance pour soutenir l'économie
l'activité et nos artisans ai les clés
parce que le haut conseil pour le climat
là encore dit le bâtiment est la
deuxième cause d'émission de gaz à effet
de serre en france et donc un gisement
énorme d'économies d'énergie et
d'efficacité en matière de lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique
et puis enfin je pense à toutes les
personnes en situation de précarité
énergétique qui vivent mal dans leur
logement dont les factures sont élevés
et que nous devons accompagner
comment faire plus le président de la
république a annoncé 15 milliards dans
le plan de relance pour la transition
écologique et la rénovation énergétique
aura toute sa place dans et déjà l'année
dernière et cette année nous consacrons
plus de trois milliards et demi à cette
politique publique d'argent budgétaire
et d'argent des grands énergéticiens
nous avons multiplié par trois le nombre
de gestes qui ont été faits par les
ménages par les particuliers l'année
dernière en matière d'isolation de
changement de chaudière
nous serons au rendez vous de cette
belle politique parce que les français
en ont besoin
merci la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue christine lagarde la varde
jeu sera plus tard pour la banque
centrale avec son talent riche de
l'avoir pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président alors là ma
question va s'adresser au ministre des
affaires étrangères donc il y a une
dizaine de jours avec bruno retailleau
président du groupe de liaison sur les
chrétiens d'orient
nous avions attiré votre attention sur
la situation des écoles d'enseignement
chrétien francophone au liban alors nous
avons eu un début de réponse cette
semaine puisque l'ambassadeur de france
au liban à tout et un plan de soutien
qui s'adresse à 53 établissements mais
53 établissements c'est loin de toucher
l'ensemble des établissements
francophones
je vous rappelle que près de 20% des
enfants libanais sont scolarisés dans ce
type d'établissement ces établissements
s'adresse à tous aussi bien aux classes
défavorisées aussi bien aux élèves
d'origine musulmane
un seul exemple à baalbeck une ville
pauvre
près de 90% des milliers d'enfants qui
sont scolarisés sont chiites alors il
est urgent d'agir et d'apporter un
soutien de la france alors que comptez
vous faire
alors je vais vous aider dans votre
réponse en vous posant trois questions
plus précises sur les 50 millions
d'euros de crédits qui sont ouverts dans
le plfr numéro 3
combien iront vers les établissements du
liban où en est la mise en oeuvre d'un
fonds de soutien spécifique aux écoles
chrétiennes du moyen-orient est il
envisagé de créer un statut d'école
associés pour les écoles non homologué
qui leur permettrait justement de
rentrer un peu dans le giron de la ffe
et de bénéficier du soutien de l'état
français pour vous répondre
la parole est aux ministres de l'europe
et des affaires étrangères monsieur le
drian
madame la varde jeu c'est l'intérêt que
vous portez au liban vous avez évoqué
des engagements concernant les questions
scolaires
d'abord l'engagement significatif que je
serai amené à rendre public quand je
vais me rendre au liban dans quelques
jours concernant les écoles homologuées
et dans le même mouvement
je rendrai public des initiatives
concernant le fonds destinés aux écoles
chrétiennes non homologué pas uniquement
lee byrne et au moyen-orient
dans le cas de ce qu'on appelle le
initiative personnages tout cela sera
public dans peu de jours mais je
voudrais me permettent d'utiliser votre
interpellation sur le liban pour vous
dire madame et dire aussi à cette
assemblée que je suis très inquiet sur
la situation et que inquiet et triste
parce qu'on sait l'histoire de la france
avec ce pays cette relation passionnelle
cette relation amicale cdh relations
historiques et on sait aussi qu'elle est
la réalité des choses aujourd'hui la
moitié de la population libanaise vit
sous le seuil de pauvreté
la livre libanaise n'arrête pas de se
déprécier las d'être ibanez n'arrête pas
d'exploser il y avait eu des engagements
de prix par les nouvelles autorités
libanaises au gouvernement de monsieur
diab qui a été mise en place au mois de
février après beaucoup de péripéties des
engagements qui étaient de faire les
réformes qu'on tout le monde souhaite
dans un délai de 100 jours
ces réformes ne sont pas au rendez vous
on sait ce qu'il faut faire sur la
transparence sur la régulation de
l'électricité sur la lutte contre la
corruption sur la réforme du système
financier et bancaire
mais rien ne bouge rien ne bouge madame
et donc je me permets de d'utiliser
cette question pour parler aux autorités
libanaises et au peuple libanais la
france et la communauté internationale
autour de la france ne pourra rien faire
si les libanais ne prennent pas les
initiatives indispensable pour leur
sursaut parce que aujourd'hui il y à un
risque d'effondrement et donc il faut
que les autorités venaient se
ressaisissent et je me permets de dire
ici à nos amis libanais vraiment nous
sommes prêts à vous aider mais aidez
nous à vous aider
bon sang
[Applaudissements]
merci finalement c'est j'aurais même eu
la réponse à la question que j'avais
posé déjà dans cet hémicycle au mois
novembre justement sur l'aide de la
france diplomatique au liban donc ça
vous avez répondu
et pour ce qui concerne les écoles
chrétiennes au moyen orient si vous
voulez répondre à l'objectif qui a été
tracée par le président de la république
lors de son discours devant l'académie
française en mars 2018 notamment doubler
le nombre d'écoles homologué accroître
le nombre d'écoles qui bénéficie du
label franck français c'est au liban que
vous allez trouver les sources puisqu'il
ya un nombre d'écoles francophones
significatif et il ya tout un tas
d'autres mesures qui ne coûtent pas cher
qui pourraient être mises en oeuvre
rapidement notamment par exemple avoir
un référent à paris qui serait une porte
d'entrée unique pour ce réseau d'écoles
ont pour essayer aussi très bien
envisager de former aux français les
professeurs et les enseignements et les
élèves ramon gratuitement au premier
niveau comme le fait le british council
si on veut continuer à accroître et à
maintenir la présence de la france dans
ce pays merci beaucoup c'est le premier
ministre mais l'âme de monsieur le
ministre
merci nous en avons terminé les
questions d'actualité
les prochaines je vous prie de bien
noter mes chers collègues en raison d'un
agenda qui de la fête nationale à la
déclaration de politique générale va
quelque peu bouleversé notre semaine les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
auront lieu le jeudi 16 juillet à 18
heures
seront donc des questions apéritive je
vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h carotte pour
l'examen des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire sur la
proposition de loi visant à encadrer le
démarchage téléphonique
la séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
avez pu suivre en intégralité en direct
sur public sénat première séance de
questions d'actualité pour le
gouvernement
castex jean castex que l'on a pu
entendre à plusieurs reprises le premier
ministre qui comme ce matin à
l'assemblée nationale s'est donné un
véritable grand oral et notamment lors
de sa première intervention en réponse à
une question porte posée par hervé
marseille
il a répété à plusieurs reprises devant
le sénat chambre de territoire que lui
même est un homme issu du territoire
l'ex maire de prades joue cette carte
ainsi que celle du dialogue et de la
confiance avec les parlementaires
écoutez le à l'ouverture de la séance
tout à leurs négociations puisque par
ailleurs la conviction que la mise en
oeuvre des politiques publiques que le
gouvernement conduira quelle qu'elle
soit passera pour être efficace par les
territoires et je suis ici dans la
chambre vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
président des territoires je suis dans
la chambre des territoires et je suis
moi même vous le savez un élu issu des
territoires et parmi les nouveaux
entrants dans ce gouvernement va tout de
suite rejoindre steve euros dans un car
il est avec barbara pour pili ministre
de la transition écologique
ces propositions sont complexes et donc
je veux qu'on le fasse bien et donc ce
texte arrivera normalement d'ici la fin
de l'été
mais si on doit le peaufiner on le
peaufine lioran référendum ça on verra
c'est pas moi qui décide
et vous quelle est votre opinion sur ce
sujet mon opinion
peu m'importe la manière ce qu'il faut
c'est que les engagements qu'on prend
pour accélérer la transition écologique
soient suivies d'effets concrets sur le
terrain et que les concitoyens voient
qu'on est en train de faire bouger les
choses
tout le reste me va à partir du moment
où on atteint cet objectif est ce qu'il
faut conditionner les aides de l'état à
la conduite en matière écologique des
entreprises
je crois que il faut qu'il y ait
vraiment une politique de donnant
donnant on doit aider les entreprises
encore plus en ce moment elles sont en
difficulté et donc il faut les soutenir
il faut soutenir le la relance de notre
économie
mais la relance de notre économie elle
doit aussi se faire en tenant compte et
même vraiment avec en son coeur les
impératifs écologiques et pour cela il
faut qu'on réussisse à travailler avec
le monde économique pour que des
engagements soient fermes et que tout le
monde joue le jeu
donc il ya pleins moyens pour le faire
des incitations des incitations des
sanctions mais tout cela doit être fait
de manière intelligente et surtout en
faisant en sorte que chacun ait le
chemin pour y arriver parce que sinon
c'est un peu facile
merci beaucoup mais la banque les avoir
répondu à mes questions voilà pourrait
bien cette interview de barbara pont pie
la ministre de la transition écologique
qui était donc au micro de style
jourdain on va tout de suite rejoindre
alexandre pousse à alexandre vous êtes
avec un philippe bas le président de la
commission des lois qui a donc tout à
l'heure interrogé mais le nouveau garde
des sceaux est réglé pour moretti et oui
pour les premiers pas d'eric
dupond-moretti ici au sénat le nouveau
ministre de la justice qui a dit aux
sénateurs
j'ai besoin de vous accordez moi le
bénéfice de l'inexpérience philippe bas
voulu accorder ce bénéfice
je lui accorde le bénéfice de
l'expérience bien sur le terrain il est
porteur d'une image forte de la justice
et comme cette image est forte et crée
aussi une forte attente il fait un
constat avec son expérience de grands
avocats qui est exact ce constat nous
l'avons fait nous aussi
il y a trois ans dans notre rapport cinq
années pour sauver la justice des
justiciables qui piétine aux portes des
tribunaux des greffiers des magistrats
qui sont submergés une administration
pénitentiaire à bout de souffle des
détenus qui sortent de prison sans être
préparés à leur réinsertion et qui vont
grossir les contingents des récidivistes
des avocats par milliers en situation
précaire eh bien il est maintenant chef
d'administration chef d'un très grand
service public essentiel à la vie de la
nation et nous attendons qu'ils portent
le souffle du renouveau du redressement
de la modernisation est ce si ça n'est
pas le discours du tribun qui est
souvent utile et nécessaire
c'est le discours et surtout l'action du
chef d'administration qui doit mettre en
oeuvre les moyens nécessaires pour
accélérer les procédures que le jugement
soit rendu plus vite qu'ils soient de
qualité que l'administration
pénitentiaire puisse être dignes d'une
grande démocratie moderne et je sais que
les agents font de tout leur coeur un
bon travail mais n'ont pas les moyens
d'accompagner les détenus vers la sortie
dans de bonnes conditions
tout ce travail il est devant nous le
garde des sceaux a mis la barre assez
haut
je crois qu'il a bien fait c'est la
bonne altitude mais maintenant c'est à
lui de franchir cette barre c'est ce que
je lui ai dit tout à l'heure
maintenant place place aux actes vous
croyez qu'il va le voir également
et bien pas s'y fier sa relation avec
les juges avec les procureurs écoutez
une nouvelle page s'ouvre ne sommes pas
là pour lui rappeler son passé le mettre
en contradiction avec lui-même le mettre
en contradiction avec madame belloubet
qui l'a précédée nous sommes là pour lui
dire si vous êtes porteur d'un nouveau
souffle pour la justice nous avons
quelques idées nous sommes prêts à
travailler avec vous mais attention nous
ne baissons pas la garde et nous voulons
que l'ambition soit la hauteur des
difficultés de ce grand service public
merci beaucoup philippe a répondu à mes
questions et donc le sénat qui a
beaucoup d'attentes concernant le
nouveau ministre de la justice
oui ce ministre de la justice qui va
être auditionné d'ailleurs par la
commission des lois philippe bas nous
l'a bien confirmé pour débriefer cette
séance exceptionnelle la première séance
du gouvernement castex j'accueille sur
ce plateau julien bargeton bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sénateur la république
en marche de paris merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous également sur ce plateau jean
bizet bonjour bonjour sénateurs à l'ère
de la manche et président de la
commission des affaires européennes et
enfin avec nous rémi féraud vous êtes
sénateur socialiste de paris et membre
de la commission des finances
mais on va tout de suite et bien
priorité au direct rejoindre et bien la
salle des conférences car mieux brigitte
qu'une carte est maintenant à notre
micro salle des conférences la nouvelle
ministre de l'insertion certainement
connaître la crise économique la plus
grave des dernières décennies et ensuite
aussi la crise sociale la plus grave des
dernières décennies
et donc nous sommes là avec le président
de la république avec le premier
ministre et le gouvernement est bien
pour nous mettre dans la bataille et
combattre cette nouvelle crise qui nous
attend cette crise sociale et pour ma
part
je suis déjà dans cette démarche est
bien de d'aller au bout de mes forces
j'ai envie de dire pour l'avoir acquis
social a déjà débuté on parle d'une
trentaine de plan social par semaine
déjà maintenant comment on fait pour
préserver l'emploi en france
mais à écouter nous le gouvernement
vient vient d'être nommé
certain nombre de mesures de relance
forte ont déjà ont déjà été prises et
nous allons avec les collègues en
prendre d'autres fortes notamment aussi
en faveur des jeunes parce que les
jeunes sont ils vont être très impacté
d'ici la rentrée c'est 700 milles à peu
près ce jeune c'est sa rentrée sur le
marché de ses membres c'est déjà une
génération sacrifiée un bas j'espère que
non et et nous sommes là pour tout faire
justement est bien pour que ces jeunes
est un avenir et qui est un espoir pour
ces jeunes le premier ministre évoquait
un décalage de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage selon vous c'est une il faut l'a
décalé où il faut tout simplement
l'abandonner ben vous savez là nous
sortons dans notre pays de la crise il
s'agit maintenant de reprendre les
projets de reprendre les dossiers pour
pour ma part et pour l'avoir vécu dans
les territoires c'est vrai que durant
ces deux mois je n'ai fait moi aussi
plus gérer j'ai envie de dire la crise
sanitaire et j'allais dire de sauver des
vies mais je pense que ça a été le cas
de grand nombre de responsables
politiques de notre pays
et maintenant il s'agit de reprendre de
ces dossiers et de voir ce qu'on va
mener au bout et dans quelle mesure et
comment nous allons le faire donc pas
d'abandon de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage selon vous mais ce sera une
question à poser plutôt au premier au
premier ministre moi je dis simplement
qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui de reprendre
les dossiers et de voir lesquels et bien
peuvent aider justement à combattre au
mieux cette situation très très
difficile que va connaître notre pays
petite dernière question vous parlez de
reprendre certains dossiers c'est le cas
de la réforme du régime des régimes de
retraite quelle qu'elles le sont les
concessions que va faire le gouvernement
quel visage aura la prochaine réforme
des retraites vous avez déjà quelques
plans dans les cartons je pense que
qu'il est prématuré aujourd'hui d'en
parler donc on attend on attend ça
n'empêche pas attendre ça veut pas dire
qu'on travaille et je peux vous dire que
le gouvernement le nouveau
comment travaille déjà d'arrache-pied
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
d'avoir répondu merci aux questions de
public sénat
voilà pour cette réaction et de cette
nouvelle arrivée 1 dans le nouveau
gouvernement castex brigitte avec les
quatre ministres de l'insertion et tout
de suite on rejoint alexandre poussard
car vous êtes avec patrick kanner le
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
et oui patrick kanner qu'est ce que vous
avez pensé des premiers pas de ce
nouveau gouvernement lors des questions
d'actualité au sénat
je pense qu'il faut un peu de rodage il
ya des anciens qui connaissent la
mécanique des culs âgées on voit bien
que le premier ministre est à l'aise
lent dans son expression mais assez
assez bonhomme si vous permettez
l'expression
bon avec quand même pour ce qui me
concerne j'ai trouvé pas mal de de
bonnes intentions qui parfois touche aux
banalités
on va attendre très sérieusement le
discours politique générale la semaine
prochaine qui me permettra de connaître
l' axe du du gouvernement et là on fera
vraiment on sera vraiment là dans le dur
et sur justement le dur et bien il a
réaffirmé qu'il voulait relancer la
concertation autour de la réforme des
retraites il y tient à ce chantier des
retraites et notamment pour équilibrer
les comptes
enfin je ne sais pas si lui il y tient
mais le président macron il tient
beaucoup puisque je me souviens
d'expression du post dans maquereau en
disant qu'on a mis à l'arrêt le pays est
donc en confinement pour protéger les
plus de 65 ans et ce n'est pas aux
jeunes de payer cette charge là et donc
il faut diminuer les cotisations
retraite ou rallongée par un âge pivot
le temps de cotisation donc on voit bien
que ça va être un chiffon rouge qui a
été dit à plusieurs reprises par les
groupes de gauche au sein de la haute
assemblée
et je trouve ça dommage parce qu'on
devrait consacrer notre énergie
absolument la reconstruction économique
et social du pays
protéger la jeunesse qui va arriver sur
le marché du travail en septembre
prochain
plutôt que de créer encore une fois un
conflit dont ne veulent pas d'ailleurs
ni les syndicats ça de salariés ni
d'ailleurs même le medef
parlons des territoires patrick kanner
est ce que vous avez le sentiment que ce
nouveau premier ministre va prendre plus
soin des territoires et mieux dialoguer
avec les collectivités avec le sénat il
vient les territoires cette année le
local voilà ça doit être clairement
clairement dit mais il ne pourra pas en
permanence dire
comme une forme de justification je suis
des territoires donc je connais les
choses ce qu'on demande du premier
ministre c'est de fixer un cap bien fuir
en lien avec le président de la
république mais un cap qui soit utile à
la france et ça pour l'instant je ne
vois pas clairement se définir non merci
beaucoup patrick kanner d'avoir répondu
à mes questions et witam les sénateurs
demandent maintenant des actes au
nouveau premier ministre il te demande
des actes oui peut-être canard il est
plutôt dubitatif
qu'avez vous pensé de jean castex jean
bizet cette première performance aussi
bien au niveau de la forme tout d'abord
puis aussi du fond qui ne se présente
comme l'homme des territoires et puis
aussi la réaffirmation effectivement que
cette réforme des retraites il veut la
faire au moins au niveau financier pour
le début je pense que de part et d'autre
du côté du premier ministre comme du
côté des parlementaires
nous sommes dans un round d'observation
on le connaît pas bien quelques-uns
parmi nous l'ont déjà rencontré mais
très peu il se présente comme un homme
de dialogue qui aller coûte je dirais
des corps intermédiaires et paraît-il
qu'il est celui qui résout les cas les
plus difficiles malheureusement je crois
qu'il va être servi parce que devant
nous sont celles je dirais une kyrielle
de problèmes de gros problèmes et
c'était déjà messieurs déconfits de
manche c'était déjà notre déconfinement
enfin me touche en plus parti à man il a
eu l'occasion de dire que nous ne
pouvions pas seul répondre à la question
il à faire un message il adressé un
message à l'europe
l europe je dirais fait ce qu'elle peut
puisque 750 milliards d'euros sur la
table et un partenaire et parmi le plus
important savoir l'allemagne qui
aujourd'hui a totalement modifié son
comportement vis-à-vis de l'ensemble des
27 états membres même question julien
bargeton et bien sûr jean castex votre
nouveau premier ministre
quelle impression vous n'avez vous
ressenti avec cette première
intervention lors de la séance de
questions d'actualité
je les trouvais
très à l'aise y compris le président du
groupe socialiste le reconnaît également
d'ailleurs au sénat il était très
déterminé très combatif
on connaît ses origines à la fois
politique locale donc c'est quelqu'un
qui a des grandes capacités pour être
premier ministre et qui a montré en
effet le sens de l'écouté des coûts des
partenaires sociaux comme des élus
locaux le sens de la méthode
et puis l'envi également est bien de
mettre en oeuvre les priorités qui sont
fixés c'est-à-dire la reconstruction
écologique et sociale la réaffirmation
du pacte républicain et puis la relance
européenne
je crois qu'il faut aussi en juger avec
ce qu'il dira au moment la déclaration
de politique générale et les oppositions
parfois on anticipe à soissons de vince
ailleurs soit ce sont des devins soit ce
on est dans la posture mais on peut pas
juger avant de d'écouter son discours de
politique générale moi je pense que il a
réussi son passage au sénat qui
interviendra donc ce discours le 15 à
l'assemblée nationale au lendemain du
discours du 14 juillet par le président
de la république un homme de territoire
un homme de dialogue qui a plutôt tenté
de séduire le sénat notamment dans sa
première allocution rémi féraud
j'imagine que vous attendez des preuves
oui parce que façon il n'avait pas dire
je ne suis pas un homme de dialogue et
je m'en fiche des territoires donc c'est
vraiment une déclaration d'intention moi
j'ai trouvé qu'en effet il était assez à
l'aise alors que l'exercice est
difficile qui nous n'a pas été
parlementaire il parle assez lentement
il répète deux fois la même phrase qui
permet aussi de ne pas trop en dire pour
le reste je trouve que passion d'edouard
philippe à jean castex passe d'un homme
de droite et de qualité et un autre
homme de droite et de qualité comme
premier ministre mais ensuite
l'important c'est la politique est
aujourd'hui nous avons été privés d'un
déclaration de politique générale
puisqu'elle avait été annoncée par le
premier ministre y est débranché par le
président de la république donc ce qui
est important sur ce que vous en
déduisez que c'était le premier couac et
que se résumera laissera peut-être pas
si facilement réduire au rôle de
collaborateur
mais j'en déduis
d'abord que sur le fond de la politique
eh bien moi j'attends avec une certaine
impatience le discours de politique le
discours de politique générale le seul
élément où on a vu une possibilité mais
non certaine de différence avec edouard
philippe c'est sur la réforme des
retraites
oui systémique paramétrique dans des
réponses que j'ai entendu du 1er mai
c'est la seule vraie différence que j'ai
entendu une différence possible ça
n'était pas clair ça n'était pas on a un
sentiment quand même que ce sera 10
haussière jean bizet oui il a déjà
annoncé que c'était quelqu'un qui
n'était pas venu pour prendre la lumière
et ça on le voit mais il ya le pendant
qui est plutôt positif
c'est celui d'être un homme de dossiers
donc on attend
il a évoqué la dépendance également
qu'est une réforme qui a été longtemps
repoussé y compris sous le précédent
quinquennat mais pas seulement réformes
difficiles mais dans les réformes qu'il
a cités il a aussi mis en avant le sujet
le sujet de la dépendance
moi je partage pas cette grille de
lecture il pense sur droite gauche mais
nous aurons de nouveau ce débat je crois
que ce que les français attendent c'est
surtout de l'efficacité et des résultats
pour le la crise économique et sociale
qui est encore devant nous mais si on va
également parlé il ya des autres
entrants dans ce gouvernement est on va
aller la salle des conférences car à
roselyne bachelot la ministre de la
culture et bien a répondu à nos
questions
roselyne bachelot vous avez souvent
affirmé que vous ne reviendriez pas en
politique pourquoi avoir fait ce choix
de revenir dans la classe politique
bonjour ja sortie c'est toujours cette
phrase je ne reviendrai pas en politique
ce si on me proposait le ministère des
cultes y intégrant donc quand on fait
une citation faut la faire c'est vrai
première chose
donc ça c'est une raison je dirais
personnel mais au delà nous sommes dans
une situation où on peut pas se défiler
devant les responsabilités
la france vient de subir un choc
économique social et sanitaire de toute
première grandeur
il ya des gens qui sont dans un état
épouvantable
les artistes en particulier bien
d'autres aussi mais les artistes les
créateurs le monde de la culture a été
totalement à l'arrêt moi qui suis une
femme de culture je vis ça dans ma chair
est évidemment dans mon coeur donc j'ai
pensé que je ne pouvais pas me défiler
devant cette responsabilité et que si je
peux apporter quelque chose à mon pays à
sa capacité de création à son
rayonnement
c'était le moment de sortir de mon petit
confort personnel mais justement vous
parlez de ce secteur culturel en crise
est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement en a fait assez pour
soutenir ce secteur culturel certains
disent qu'il fait partie des grands
oubliés de la crise alors je ne peux pas
laisser dire cela immédiatement mon
collègue franck riester a pris la mesure
de tout cela il y a évidemment le
secteur un secteur qui en bénéficient de
toutes les mesures générales d'urgence
le chômage partiel les pauses emprunt
galets prêts garantis et les fonds de
solidarité ça représente quand même pas
loin de 3 milliards d'euros
des mesures spécifiques on pense au
fonds d'urgence pour le spectacle vivant
il y a eu effectivement d'autres mesures
qui vont
arrivée qui sont déjà arrivés comme des
mesures spécifiques et puis on prépare
un projet de loi de finances
rectificative qui va à nouveau mobilisés
1,06 milliard d'euros avec des
dispositions fiscales des dispositions
sociales de des crédits budgétaires
directs et puis s'ajoutera évidemment
quelque chose qui tient très à coeur au
président de la république cette année
blanche pour ce qu'on appelle les
intermittents techniciens ou artistes
qui bénéficieront jusque en août 2000 21
des dispositions dérogatoires de
dispositions dérogatoires qui vont
permettre de bénéficier de
l'intermittent ce n'est pas suffisant 1
parce que le choc a été terrible mais
dans le plan de relance il y aura aussi
des dispositions nous sommes en train de
discuter avec d'autres ministres puisque
on sait bien que le président de la
république a décidé c'est peut-être une
première que le plan de relance serait
économique social environnemental et
culturel alors un mot sur votre retour
ici au sénat vous arrivé un peu en
terrain conquis car vous connaissez une
partie de la majorité de droite ici au
sénat en terrain conquis je ne sais pas
si je reviens au sénat en terrain
conquis je viens plutôt sénat en terrain
à conquérir à conquérir par mon action
accomplir par mon implication
rien n'est jamais gagné au sénat parce
que les sénateurs il ne voulut jamais
sur des paroles il vous eu sur des actes
alors effectivement j'ai retrouvé
beaucoup de visages amis et ça ça fait
toujours très plaisir mais c'est pas ça
qui m'attend c'est de gagner des
arbitrages ces deux voilà et puis
d'avoir le soutien des sénateurs de tous
bords j'ai toujours su fracturé les les
frontières politiques j'espère que je
continuerai vous allés fracturer les
clivages comme emmanuel macron
comme au zimbabwe très bien merci
beaucoup roselyne bachelot d'avoir
répondu à mes questions comme roselyne
bachelot c'est bien répondu jean bizet
bien c'est quand même une belle prise
issus de vos rangs qui attire énormément
de sympathie roselyne bachelot donc il
rejoint le ministère de la culture
je ne sais pas si on peut parler de
prise parce que roselyne bachelot dit
elle même elle a toujours transgresser
sur tous les dossiers là sa personnalité
les cas messieurs de la droite
elle est issue de la droite mais elle a
su faire un certain nombre de
transactions sur des dossiers je dirais
qu'ils pour la droite était également
clivant on va voir ce qu'elle va je
dirais mettre en oeuvre c'est vrai que
la culture aujourd'hui ce qui n'est pas
mon domaine
je dirais d'activité est en grande
difficulté mais moi j'en attend
également beaucoup à titre personnel en
tant qu'élu de normandie et de la manche
en particulier parce que nous avons les
piques du mont-saint-michel que son
prédécesseur avait eu le courage
politique de mettre en oeuvre il faut
aujourd'hui qu'il rentre dans sa phase
opérationnelle je lui ai déjà demandé
vous êtes allé chercher l'incarnation
avec roselyne bachelot si une
personnalité forte pour prendre le
ministère de la culture ce qui a
peut-être manqué jusqu'ici frangine
bachelot est une femme très populaire
moi j'ai l'apprécient beaucoup à titre
personnel à ma cuisine est parfois sur
ses plateaux mais je me souviens son
combat pour le pacs où elle était isolé
dans sa famille politique où elle a fait
preuve d'un grand courage en allant au
bout de ses convictions elle a toujours
défendu les personnes lesbiennes gaies
bi et trans roselyne bachelot et puis
c'est une affaire c'est une femme oui
cette jeune femme c'est une femme de son
temps de son époque et qui est une
grande passionnée de culture est plus
que ça vous voyez qu'elle connaît déjà
très bien ses dossiers à l'appui
absolument tout citer c'est à la fois
une grande connaisseuse personnel et
intime de la culture parce que c'est une
femme de culture et c'est une femme qui
connaît très bien les politiques
culturelles ce qui est aussi important
il faut dire qu'elle a du pain sur la
planche roselyne bachelot le monde de la
culture sorte extrêmement affaibli de
cette période du coc vide
rémi féraud il ya de très grosses
attentes oui et je crois que roselyne
bachelot l'a dit dans son intervention à
l'instant
l'enjeu pour elle c'est d'obtenir des
arbitrages si roselyne bachelot peut
obtenir des arbitrages pour que la
culture ne soit pas la grande oubliée de
cette période et du plan de relance
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui non pas
que rien n'ait été fait mais vraiment
pas assez et pour coup moins que pour
d'autres secteurs et la france sans lac
la condition tous la culture c'est aussi
des emplois fins mais celle aussi non
mais c'est aussi l'âme d'un pays où en
france voilà si elle peut obtenir des
arbitrages c'est vraiment ça l'enjeu
pour elle sinon en dehors des effets de
casting il y aura très vite une grande
déception
l'autre effet de casting est très
attendu et bien c'est bien sûr l'arrivée
d'eric dupond-moretti qui donc devient
garde des sceaux jean bizet qu'avez-vous
pensé et bien des interventions du ténor
du barreau qui n'a pas semblé toujours à
l'aise lors de cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement c'est un
exercice très différent que de prendre
la parole dans l'hémicycle
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire il est
dans une posture de d'ailleurs qui la
qualifie lui-même de beaucoup d'humilité
appelant l'ensemble des sénatrices et
sénateurs à l'aider à accomplir sa
mission
mais je dirais qui il n'a pas raté cette
prestation parce que il n'a pas voulu
dominer ce qui aurait été d'une très
grande maladresse et il n'y en avait pas
aujourd'hui les codes mais je pense
qu'on peut en attendre beaucoup parce
qu'aujourd'hui il est vrai la situation
de ce service public de la justice est
en grand déshérence sur tous les points
dans notre pays
alors peut-être il fallait appeler cette
personnalité qui connaît bien le sujet
mais sous une autre face au lycée ses
chances alors j'en vivrais aussi avec
absolue philippe bas on voit cinq
personnalités là encore qui plaît à la
droite mais qui va devoir faire ses
preuves et très vite car une audition
est annoncée julien bargeton il faut
laisser le temps à eric dupond-moretti
de faire ses preuves on n'est pas dans
un exercice de bizutage qui serait
malvenu je veux dire il est l'arrivée
depuis deux jours c'est quelqu'un qui
connaît comme il le dit la justice de
l'intérieur par son rôle et son métier
d'avocat et donc il a effectivement fait
preuve d'humilité
l'épreuve fait preuve d' écoute il veut
mais un peu comme des et de proximité
parce que ce qui est important ce
service de proximité un peu comme le
premier ministre l'a dit sur les
hôpitaux quand le ministre a dit faut
faire revenir les maires à l'hôpital je
crois que c'était comme en filigrane de
toutes ces interventions c'est ce qui
est important c'est le travail qui sera
mené notamment sa proximité donc en
effet eric dupond moretti a voulu
montrer qu'il était qu'il voulait
écouter qui voulait apprendre
il l'a dit à prendre aussi des
parlementaires et on sait aller mi mai
mais ces housses et à l'épreuve des
faits dans l'efficacité qu'on verra le
midi la justice qu'il est mes positions
et d'humilité qui a assumé avec des
points noirs et il devant les
parlementaires et puis là aussi tenter
de recoller les morceaux avec les
magistrats
hier lors de la passation de pouvoir car
il a eu des mots très durs à l'égard est
bien de ces magistrats il ya quelques
jours en portant plainte dans la sphère
et bien des fadettes de ses fadettes qui
avaient été consultés qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire rien la république a pris
des risques en le nommant ça passe ou ça
casse dix mois mais il a fait aussi
parce que sinon en dehors du changement
de premier ministre personne ne se
serait rendu compte qu'il y avait eu un
remaniement ministériel
donc ce que l'on aime beaucoup de
continuité dans le dans l'équipe ça
marque les esprits
eric dupond moretti ensuite est-ce que
ça fait partie uniquement de la société
du spectacle
ou est ce que ce sera un bon minitieux
incapable de vous répondre et je pas
être dans le procès d'intention
ce qui est vrai c'est que dans la
réponse aux questions au sénat
il a raté l'exercice parce qu'il était
presque hors de l'exercice il n'y a pas
un quart d'heure ou une demi-heure pour
mettre la cour dans son ambiance
il faut aller vite et à l'essentiel il a
plus parlé de lui qu'il n'a répondu aux
questions qui lui étaient posées sur la
justice la question plus sérieusement
que ça pose c'est gouvernement de combat
opérationnel tout de suite il connaît
bien la justice il ne pourra pas très
longtemps dire laissez moi découvrir mes
dossiers et apprendre mon métier c'est
fin c'est pas le problème des français
c'est pas le problème du monde de la
justice
l'ag parce qu'il faut qu'ils changent
vite son son discours pour conclure et
bien sûr une personne qui n'est pas
arrivée qui étaient déjà là mais qui a
changé de poste et ça fait aussi
beaucoup parler c'est gérald darmanin
je vous propose de l'écouter tout à
l'heure lors de la séance de questions
d'actualité avant mais du coup ne l'a
pas eh ben c'est pas grave on va donc
pas l'écouter mais on va se rappeler ce
qu'a pu dire gérald darmanin le ministre
de l'intérieur il a estimé jean bizet
que et bien jacqueline eustache brinio
était caricatural dans sa vision de la
laïcité
bien qu'ils soient issus de la droite on
voit là un vrai désaccord est bien avec
une partie de vos rangs oui absolument
je suis déçu je suis déçu de ce que de
ce qu'il a pu répondre à notre collègue
parce que elle était au plus proche des
territoires dans sa collectivité au plus
proche des réalités alors darmanin nous
a habitués si je puis dire à des
discours beaucoup plus musclé étonné de
sa part c'est oui je pensais que je
pensais qu'il allait avoir un peu plus
de courage politique
là il a pas pris la bonne
le bon chemin à mon avis la question
était quand même caricatural je le
trouve
gérald morin a rappelé qu'était la
république la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité de la liberté de croire ou de
ne pas croire la fraternité laïque il a
rappelé en effet qu'il fallait lutter
contre des phénomènes de radicalisation
exhaure absolument qui existent et qui
sont et qui sont choquants mais qu'il ne
fallait pas faire des généralisations
donc en fait c'est ce qu'il a appelé un
ami personnel qui a nommé
oui avec une référence personnes
priaient allah et défendez les valeurs
de la république et non mais ni naïveté
ni généralisation
ou alors est donc il a rappelé la
république tout simplement ça vous a
étonné de la part de ministres du
nouveau ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin ce discours sur la laïcité rémi
féraud non d'abord c'est par un discours
c'est une réponse très brève
j'ai entendu aussi ce qu'il a dit lors
de sa prise de fonction oui mais oui
j'ai trouvé la question caricaturale
d'une certaine manière ça rendait plus
simple la réponse du ministre qui a pu
se situer plus en équilibre par rapport
à une question caricaturale alors qu'il
avait exprimé une grande fermeté sur
l'islam politique au moment de sa prise
de fonction ce changement de ministre de
l'intérieur
c'est là aussi un vrai défi pour
emmanuel emmanuel macron parce que
christophe castaner n'a pas réussi dans
cette dans cette fonction
walo qui est une fonction extrêmement
difficile mais j'ai trouvé que
finalement gérald darmanin poursuivre et
son dialogue avec ses anciens amis des
républicains comme lorsqu'il était
ministre du budget nous en avions
l'habitude avec julien bargeton en
sommes à la commission des finances
souvent c'était un dialogue voilà
c'était encore la famille dont il est
issu saint louis puis avec une haie ils
aiment débattre
ils aiment débattre gérald darmanin jean
visait le mot de la fin sur ce que vous
vous attendez finalement et bien de la
suite parce que c'est un gouvernement de
mission de rassemblement a dit manière
macro mais surtout qui doit faire face à
une crise sans précédent va falloir
maintenant rentrer dans le concret parce
que les problèmes vont arriver en g aux
biens bargeton moi je trouve que c'est
un gouvernement de grande qualité qui
concilie la continuité c'est normal que
aux armées ou à aux affaires étrangères
on est gardé les mêmes ministres parce
que la crise n'a pas changé sa est en
revanche il ya des nouvelles
personnalités qui arrive et puis il ya
des défis qui sont devant nous en 5
secondes
rémi féraud le mot de la fin je pense
pas qu'ils aient dans ce changement de
gouvernement
matière à rebonds nous verrons bien là
discuter de la déclaration de politique
générale ensuite il ya merci beaucoup
d'avoir participé tous les trois ce
premier débrief et bien des questions au
gouvernement
de jean castex merci à tous d'avoir
assisté à cette émission très bonne
soirée sur public sénat
[Musique]